(Joey smacks lips)
- I actually wash my
phone, like, once a week.
- You wash your phone?
- I don't know, I just, I don't like it.
It gets, like, shit on it,
I don't really like it.
- [Meilyne] Gets shit on it?
(everyone laughs)
- I shit on my phone, Meilyne!
- Why do we talk about
shit, like, every time?
- No, Mudan, don't fucking use this.
- Use this.
Do it.
(chill music plays)
- Welcome to this episode of,
wait, which episode are we on?
- I don't fucking know.
- [Meilyne] 43.
- 43.
- Welcome to episode 43, I heard,
wait what is this?
- We've never said an episode number
in the history of "Trash Taste."
- I love, "welcome to episode,"
"47."
(everyone laughs)
Just don't mention the episode name.
- We've never mentioned
an episode number before.
- I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna fuckin' do it.
It's 43.
Welcome back to this
episode of "Trash Taste."
And once again, I'm with the boys.
Who is Joey, who is Garnt?
That's the answer to the boys.
- Thank you.
- I didn't realize-
- What is this "Jeopardy?"
(everyone laughs)
Who is Joey?
Correct.
- Who is Garnt?
No, sorry.
Grant, sorry.
- Here's your daily double.
Who is Grant?
- I've never watched "Jeopardy" before.
- Really?
- It's good fun actually.
- So, why do they have to
answer like, "what is,"
like, "Grant," or whatever?
- I don't know.
- Because what they,
instead of the question,
they give you, like, an answer,
and then the answer is the question.
So, it's like reverse trivia.
- Grown man finds out what "Jeopardy" is.
- I've only seen, like, out
of context "Jeopardy" tweets,
or "Jeopardy" clips,
and I've just always tried to figure out
why are they answering in questions?
- I feel like it's pretty easy
to figure out what's going on.
- Now that you've explained it.
Of course it's going to be easy
now that you've explained it.
- No one had to tell me what was going on.
I was like, I'm guessing
based on, you know,
what's going on.
- I can't recall the moment
in my life where I was like,
"I need to know how this game works."
- Good job, Garnt.
- I can't even remember the
last time I watched a game show.
It's just, yeah.
- Did you watch any game shows growing up?
- Yeah, I actually watched quite a lot.
- We have quite good ones in the UK.
- Yeah, like "How To Be a Millionaire."
That was a classic, classic game.
- Did you guys have,
like, "Deal or No Deal?"
- What country originally made that?
- America
- America, but we had,
like, an Australian version.
- Yeah, the British one
went for a long time.
- Who was the host?
Noel Edmonds, yeah.
- Noel Edmonds.
- Have you seen the
American "Deal or No Deal?"
- No.
- It's like "Deal or No Deal"
but, like, it's way more Hollywood-ized.
- Is it literally just like
the "Kitchen Nightmares" deal
where like "Kitchen
Nightmares USA" is like,
"You won't believe what happened."
And then the UK one is
like, Gordon's like,
"All right, come on.
"You gotta get your act together."
- It's just, it's way bigger.
They got like, you know,
instead of just fuckin' Noel Edmonds,
like, opening the briefcase or something,
they've got, like, the proper, you know,
boxing ring chicks that like, you know-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, like, the
models'll open up the briefcase,
and you compare it to,
like, the British version,
and it's just night and day.
- Wait, does the British
version not have, 'cause-
- We have the boxes, we have the boxes.
- We have the boxes.
- Oh, 'cause in Australia
they took the American thing,
and lined up, like, 30 chicks.
- Should we explain what
"Deal or No Deal" is
for someone who might not know?
- Okay.
- It's basically like
a contestant comes on,
opens a bunch of briefcases.
- They have to get down to-
- How do you explain "Deal or No Deal?"
- Oh, wait so they get down
to two boxes, don't they?
- Yeah, okay.
So, if I remember correctly, you have,
I can't remember like 15
boxes or 15 briefcases.
- It's like 25.
- 25?
- It's, like, a lot, yeah.
- And I believe you have to, like,
you have to choose random briefcases and-
- They get knocked out.
- And then like every briefcase
has a different amount
of money in it, and when
you choose that briefcase,
that amount of money is knocked
out of the prize pool and-
- No, but isn't it, they
pick a briefcase first,
and they hang onto it,
but they don't know what
it is until the very end.
- Yeah, yeah, and there's
basically what they do is
is the reason why they
don't just immediately skip
to the final one which you pick is
because along the way based on
what you've knocked out or got in,
so say you've knocked out
all the lower prize pools
like the 1,000 pounds, the
2,000, they'll offer you deals.
So, the whole point of the
show is that you kind of want
to knock out all the small ones at first,
so that they might offer
you a really generous deal
'cause your box might be, like,
the one that's left that sucks.
It was always a really fun game
show, and I really liked it.
But in the UK,
I don't know if this is
the same in Australia,
but, like, all ages watch,
like, the quiz show or the-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I just couldn't see, like,
my grandma watching, like,
bikini models fuckin' open up boxes.
- Dude, my grandma was fuckin' obsessed
with "Deal or No Deal."
- Oh, my great grandma too as well.
She watched it every day.
- Yeah, wait, but did
you guys not have, like,
the supermodels with briefcases?
- No, our game shows are,
like, unapologetically, like,
just, like, chill people just doing, like,
normally for small amounts of money.
- But then on the opposite
of the side of the spectrum,
you guys have shows
like "Naked Attraction."
- Yeah, I mean, I don't know.
- I mean, that's still a
small scale, I would say.
- Even like "Pointless,"
which has been, like,
if you don't know what "Pointless"
is it's kind of hard to,
just fuckin' Google it.
I don't wanna explain
every single game show
that we talk about.
"Pointless," the prize
pool was only ever, like,
1,000 pounds, right?
- Yeah.
- Really?
- Which is, like, to go
on, you know, national TV
for like what?
Like, $1,500, no $1,300?
Not really a lot.
That's if you win.
You get nothing if you don't.
- At least "Deal or No Deal" had, like,
I think the prize pool, the
top prize pool was, like,
a million dollars or something.
- $250,000.
- $250,000 or pounds for the UK one.
- Oh, really?
In Australia it was like a million.
- I think that's not too far off.
- I mean, you never saw
anyone winning the million.
- Prize pools in general
in the UK quiz shows are
pretty small, except
for, like, the big ones
which are marked as, like, the big ones.
- I think the biggest one we had was
"Who Wants To Be a Millionaire?"
- That was the whole show.
- I mean, I think that was the
biggest one anywhere, right?
- But then like,
UK version was probably,
like, the most expensive,
just like, fuck.
Why is our currency so goddamn strong?
- A million pounds is a lot of money!
- Imagine a Japanese "Who
Wants To Be a Millionaire?"
(everyone laughs)
- We have that.
- Do you just win a million yen?
- Like, 10 grand.
- I think, wait, what is it again?
Ashley, do you remember,
like, how much money is it
for the Japanese "Who
Wants To Be a Millionaire?"
- [Ashley] I didn't even know.
- Oh, nevermind.
I'm pretty sure it's a million.
No, it's 10 million yen.
- That would make sense.
- We spoke about it before.
I remember like "Takeshi's Castle."
Like, the Japanese version,
I think it was three
million yen was the prize.
I thought for a game
show that fucking hard
$30,000 doesn't seem like
a fair reward for a show
that only like five people ever won.
- But in most Japanese quiz shows-
- It's not about the money.
- Well, it is about the money,
but when it is about the money,
the max you get is like 10K.
And usually that's split
because, like, usually it's,
like, a team-based thing.
- Oh no.
- So, it's like, "You guys win 10K,
"split between the five of you."
So, and then after taxes you
probably get a grand each.
- What's your, like, favorite Australian
or, like, American game
show that you've ever seen?
- God...
I'd probably say "Deal or No
Deal" was probably my favorite.
- I really liked "Family Fortunes."
I don't know what the
American one is, but-
- "Family Feuds?"
- "Family Feuds."
I've seen, like, the American,
like, clips of the American one,
and that seems as fun if not even better
than the British version.
- Because, like, on the American
one I feel like they have,
like, more celebrities to choose from.
- Exactly!
- We only have like a few
very giant celebrities.
- Yeah, we had like Les Dennis,
which I don't even remember
what he was famous for
in the first place.
- Because like in America
you have, like, celebrities,
which normally are known,
like, the world over
just 'cause how it is.
But in the UK you have like
two tiers of celebrities
which are like legit, like,
massive celebrities known
all around the world.
Like, you know, like,
normally musical artists
or, like, really big actors.
- And then the local-
- And then you have, like,
the locally known ones,
which are normally like just, like,
the comedians are pretty good.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But, like, outside of
that, you have, like,
someone who's like, he
said a racist word on TV
and made a career out of it one time.
Like, all right, okay.
- Same with Australia.
I mean, it's same in Australia.
It's like, you're either
an internationally known,
like, star who's hosting the show
or you're an Australian
comedian that failed to, like,
market themselves outside of Australia.
So, it's just like,
"We'll give you a spot.
"You speak in an Australian accent."
- We had this one game show.
I think it was, I don't know
if it was British first.
It was called "Golden Balls."
Did you ever watch this?
- Oh yeah, I did watch that.
Yeah, yeah, that was cool.
- I know, I know.
- Tee hee, golden balls.
- So what would happen is is
that they would get, like,
five balls each
and they all had different
amounts of money in them.
And then you have to,
like, negotiate, I think...
- No, no, no, so-
- Who to kickoff?
- So, no, no, no.
- Like, a football game.
- I haven't actually seen it,
but I've, I think we're
thinking of the right one
where the last round-
- The last round is the best one.
- Is the most interesting one.
So, you have a prize pool,
and it's I think it's based on, like,
the prisoner's dilemma or something.
I'm probably wrong on that.
So, you have two people, and
you basically have to agree
if you're going to share the prize pool.
Or, like, okay so-
- You have to steal or share.
- Yeah, you can steal
the entire prize pool,
or you can share the prize pool.
And if you share, if
both people pick share
then you share the prize money.
But if one person picks steal,
they get the entire
amount of the prize money.
But if both people pick steal,
then nobody gets the prize money.
- You just saw, like,
the biggest pieces of shit on this show.
Like, yeah, you'd win the money, but like-
- That really seems like a show to, like,
expose the worst side of humanity.
- It was brutal, right?
'Cause this TV show fuckin' loved it.
'Cause they were like,
"Bro, whatever you gotta
do to get this money,
"you ham it up."
So, these people would do
like massive sob stories
to the person next to them,
and they would believe them.
They'd be like, "Man, my kids, you know,
"they need this thing real bad, man."
They're like, "They need this
expensive thing," et cetera.
And then they, you know, they would do it
and then they reveal it like
they stole all the money
and everyone's like, okay,
sure you won 10 grand,
but at what cost?
- At what cost?
They go through their entire
life story to be like,
"I'm a devout Christian.
"I've given to charity.
"I am the most honest
person you could ever meet
"in your life.
"JK."
- They literally did a
Dio and was just like,
"I'm going to reject humanity,
(everyone laughs)
"to get this money."
- I remember this one guy-
- I think I've seen the same clip.
- Which one?
Which one was it?
- The guy who just fucking hacked,
like, social hacked the
game where he was just like,
"Look mate, I'm gonna pick steal."
(Joey laughs)
- Yeah, I've seen it.
- Such a, like, a fivehead move.
He literally goes to the guy,
"Look, I'm not even gonna pretend.
"I'm going to pick steal, okay?
"And what I'm going to do is
"I'm going to share half
the prize money with you
"once the game's over."
And the other guys was like,
"No, you can't do that."
Like, "No, we're gonna pick share.
"We're gonna at least
agree to pick share."
He's like, "Nope, I'm picking steal,
"and you're gonna have to trust me
"that I'm going to share the prize money
"after the show ends."
And, like, the other guy asked the host,
"Is this allowed?
"Is this actually allowed?"
And the host goes.
"Whatever happens after this
show, we can't guarantee."
So he's like-
- So if you get shanked,
that's your issue.
- Yeah, yeah, so he's like,
"Well, I'm going to pick
steal as well then."
And he's like, "Fine, if you pick steal,
"we're both going to lose the money.
"But the only chance you're
gonna have to gain money is
"by picking share."
Such a fucking fivehead move.
- Asshole move.
- That's like reverse reverse psychology.
- No, but at the end he didn't pick steal.
He picked share.
So, both of them got the
prize money in the end.
- Oh shit.
- Wow.
- And I was just like, dude,
this guy is the main protagonist
of the fucking universe.
What a fivehead move, man.
- That is literally, like, the martyr.
(everyone laughs)
"I'll be the bad guy so
that everyone can win."
- Like, I just watched, like,
IRL "Code Geass" right in front of me.
- That is literally "Code Geass."
- This is what I saw right here.
- I saw, like, I swear,
I don't know if this
was like a popular clip.
I remember one time a guy, like,
literally came into the show,
'cause there's four contestants
at the start, I believe.
He was literally just right
from the start being like,
"I'm gonna steal.
"I'm gonna steal no matter what."
And then he stole.
And then he didn't get anything
because the person also stole.
So, it's like the same thing,
but like small brain version.
He was like, "I'm gonna
steal," to everyone.
Everyone's like, "Yeah, we know."
(everyone laughs)
"I'm not giving you anything."
- "So am I."
- Imagine you wait for months, right,
and you go through all
the interviews and shit,
you get on the show finally,
you have a chance of winning money,
and some fucking asshole
immediately said to everyone,
"I'm gonna ruin the show for all of you.
"I don't give a fuck."
You'd be like, "Well fuck.
"What am I supposed to do?
- That's like the,
what's the fuck the thing?
"The Millionaire Hot Seat" thing as well.
Did you have those?
- No, we don't have that I don't think.
- Okay, 'cause I don't
know if it was in America.
We definitely had it in Australia though.
So, there's like, you know,
there's like "Who Wants
To Be a Millionaire?"
which is just like a one-on-one thing.
There was this other version of it called
"Millionaire Hot Seat"
which is basically, it's
one game of millionaire,
but then there's, like, four
other people basically, like,
sitting on the benches, waiting
for the person to fuck up.
And if one person gets the answer wrong-
- They swap?
- Then it goes to the next
person from where they started.
- It's pretty cool.
- And so I saw this clip,
which is like you start
off with five people.
- Right.
- And they got to, I don't
know, it was like the 2,000,
you know, not even
halfway up kind of thing.
And I guess it was, like,
a really hard question.
So, the first guy gets it wrong,
and he's like, "Oh fuck.
"All right, whatever.
"See you later."
Next person comes on fully
confident being like,
"Well he just basically
"just got rid of one
of the answers for me.
"I got this."
And not only does he get it wrong,
but then the next person during 50/50,
he also gets it wrong.
So, the fourth person comes up, is like,
"So, there's only one answer remaining.
"I think it's this one."
It's like, "You're correct!"
But, like, imagine waiting,
sitting on the benches
all that time to just come up and be like,
"Thank you for giving me this money."
- "Thank you for the free money."
- "Thank you for the free money.
"JK, see ya later."
- I'm trying to remember
what else was there.
"The Weakest Link."
You remember "The Weakest Link?"
- Yeah, 'cause remember,
like, what's his name?
Was it Phil or Dan?
Which one of them was
on "The Weakest Link?"
- Oh, were they actually?
- Yeah one of them-
- The YouTubers?
- Yeah, one of them was
on "The Weakest Link."
- What's "The Weakest Link?"
- Oh, it's this,
it's not going anymore, is it?
- I don't think so.
- There was this really
popular daytime British TV show
where we had this, like, really, like,
she was famous for being
like bitch basically.
'Cause that was her whole
character was that she was rude.
- Yeah, I can't remember her name.
- And it was just a quiz show.
And basically, like, it
would just keep going
and asking questions,
and you basically, like,
at the end of the question
round, they'd ask eight people,
you have to vote someone off,
and it was normally the person
who was letting the team down
because if you've got a question wrong,
you, like, ruined the streak.
And it's like a video game
where more streak, more points.
So, if someone gets a
question wrong, they ruin it,
and then you get less money.
And if you, so, like,
as it's going around,
so if I get one right, I get 100 points.
Then you get 200, then 400,
and someone has to like say "bank,"
so that the points get saved.
So, the streak can keep
going until someone saves it.
So, if you're the one who's like,
"I'm gonna get the big boy question,"
and then you fuck it up and lose the money
that everyone just earned,
you're probably gonna get voted off.
- Right, right.
- But then, like, there was
a meta game behind it as well
because if you were too good,
then people would just like
gang up on you and vote you off
because they didn't have
as much a chance of winning
if you were on the game show.
- Right.
Sounds brutal.
- And I think, I can't
remember which one it was.
It was Dan or Phil.
One of them was on it before
they became a YouTuber.
- Oh, wow.
- Yeah, it's really good.
You should watch it.
And then, like, the host is
just, like, roasting them.
- That sounds fun.
- It's really endearing watching someone
before they were a YouTuber, like, do it.
It was just, I don't know.
It was really fun.
- I've always wanted to be on,
like, trivia shows like that.
- Yeah, I mean, I think
I'd like to go on a show
that has like,
literally that is just like,
hey, this is just a game show.
Just go up and do it.
Like, no, like acts.
No fuckin' like,
"Hey, play this character."
No, just let me just fuckin' go on
and make a fool of myself.
- Like, is there like a what's really,
are game shows still going on?
- Yeah, they are.
I think, like, it's like,
I'd like to think that most game shows are
the complete opposite of,
like, the talent shows.
'Cause the talent shows are
just heavily scripted
narratives and all this stuff.
- I think we just don't know
'cause we don't watch TV.
- Yeah, I just stopped watching TV,
so I actually have no
fucking idea anymore.
- Yeah.
Me too.
There was this YouTuber
now who's uploading,
he entered an American talent
show that I'd never heard of.
I think he's called
Reckless Ben on YouTube,
and he's like, he basically
signed up for this thing
and then wore secret
glasses while he's on it.
So, now he's uploading videos
of him behind the scenes,
and his narration is really fuckin' funny.
And yeah, now they're just, like,
threatening him to take the videos down.
- [Joey] Yeah, of course.
- And he's uploading videos being like,
"I'm not gonna take it down.
"Here's the next video."
- "I'm taking it down."
- It's great.
It's really interesting-
- Living up to his name.
- Yeah, 'cause he's
just, like, he's in it,
and he's just narrating really stupid,
and he's just like a complete clown
in like the best way possible.
Yeah, it's really interesting.
You should watch these YouTube videos.
I didn't sell it very well.
I feel like, I don't
wanna explain too much.
You should just go watch them.
It's really, really underrated.
No one's watching these videos.
They have like 80K, 100K.
- It's still a decent amount.
- Well, for something,
like, as crazy as this,
you'd think it'd be a lot bigger.
- Is it like even a big
kind of exposure that,
hey, this is kind of faked
and it's all scripted.
- It's really fun just seeing,
like, a producer go up to him
and be like, "No, not now,"
or, "Hey, this is your," like,
oh, like, you know like
when the crowd's cheering?
He shows, like, the
video footage of, like,
what's the show see then he
cuts to what's happening to him,
and it's just him in the
middle of a giant stage
and there's nothing.
Like, no noise or anything.
It's really funny.
- I think there's a big difference
between just like hearing
and knowing that it's rigged
versus actually seeing
that it's rigged.
- You know like all those
talent shows as well have, like,
onsite therapists because of, like,
how, like, brutal the schedule is.
Like, some of them,
in like "America's Got Talent"
had to, like, sit around
for like 19 hours to,
like, wait to practice.
- Fucking hell.
- Jesus Christ.
- So, they had onsite
therapists and they would, like,
and there was, like, cases
where they're injecting them
with, like, vitamins and
stuff to keep them awake
during the show.
- What the fuck?
- Yeah, and then obviously, you know,
these contracts you sign
which have come up before
for like "X-Factor" in the UK.
- It's horrible.
- Oh my God, like some of them,
I swear it was "X-Factor UK"
where you literally sign away your rights
to anything you've ever done online
and anything you do in future ever.
Like, if you became a
YouTuber, they own it.
Like, you can't do it
without their permission.
- It's fucked.
- It's nuts.
Like, I get why they do it
'cause they want to cover their ass,
but they go, like, so beyond
where it's like, this is kind of like-
- This is kind of just exploitive now.
People want their five minutes
of fame, right, that's why.
- And it's like, what are you gonna do?
Get five minutes of fame yourself?
No, I don't think so.
What are you gonna do?
Build a career?
Good one.
- "Not without my help."
- Yeah, exactly.
Not without Simon Cowell fucking
breathing down your throat.
I don't think so.
- Jesus Christ.
- I'll tell you what Sydney's
been watching recently.
She's been like, she's gone
off the true crime for a bit,
and she's just-
- Oh has she?
- Yeah, she's now turned over to trash TV,
reality trash TV.
She's been watching "90 Day Fiance."
- Bro, I could just feel the scripts
when I'm watching that show.
Like, you can tell that the
producers have made them do,
like, two, three takes.
- [Joey] Of course.
- It's awful.
I can't stand it.
I watched like one whole season of it,
and it was just like, they just repeat-
- You watched one whole season?
- I've watched a whole season.
- I'm impressed.
- How?
- I don't know.
I really don't know.
I didn't enjoy half of it either.
I was watching it and it's just like,
they go in fuckin' circles.
They'll be like,
so they'll meet up and they'll be like,
"Yeah, it's kind of weird,
but we just love each other."
And then there'll just be, like,
red flags right from the start.
"He asked me to PayPal him like 10 grand."
You know, "He doesn't want to have kids.
"I want to have kids.
"But you know, I think love has a way."
And it's like-
- The shittiest, like, love drama, right?
- Because I feel like watching
"90 Day Fiance," right-
- I lose brain cells watching this show.
- I lose brain cells
watching it, but I think it,
like, I imagined what if it aired, like,
on Twitch or something?
I think it would be a
fuckin' excellent experience
if something like that aired on Twitch.
- Like, unscripted?
- Huh?
- No, I mean just, like, watching
with, like, the Twitch chat
to see all the reactions.
That's like part of the fun.
- The worst part about watching
it, like, in seasons was,
like, without the YouTube comments,
"90 Day Fiance" is like 90% less enjoyable
because the best comments were, like,
making sure that everyone agrees with you
on who's the bigger asshole.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- It's, like, literally
like the real life version
of am I the asshole, you know?
You know, you go there
to see the spicy drama
but watching it by yourself,
I feel is just you lose half
of the enjoyment out of it.
- How did you sit through,
like, a normal episode of that?
- Oh, it was hard.
- Because, like, I watched,
'cause obviously, like,
anybody I got into it
through the fuckin' Ed and
Rose clips that went around.
- Yeah, me too.
- So, I was just like, oh,
if the clips are this good
then I'm pretty sure the
entire episode is good.
It's not.
- Well, 'cause like the-
- It's such a drag.
- It is one of those TV shows
where like the clip is
the best way to watch it.
Watching this was, like, brutal.
Like, none of these couples
are, like, good people.
They're all just, like,
the worst people doing the
shittiest things to each other
and then being surprised
when none of it works.
And it's like, it is horrible.
- I mean, like, it's trash TV,
but I mean, you know why
you're watching it, right?
No one's watching it to be like,
maybe this situation will work out.
And this girl's like, you know,
"This guy who's on his 10th marriage
"and I've only known for three months,
"I don't know if he really loves me."
- It is like those-
- What, no way!
- That's what it's like!
- It is like someone has made a playbook
of like the worst setups to relationships.
There's always like someone
who can't speak the
other person's language,
so they just can't communicate.
- Most of the time it's that, right?
- It's like, what the fuck are you doing?
Meilyne!
- What the hell was that?
- We're recording!
- You watching "90 Day Fiance" over there?
- Meilyne's just loading up an
episode right now apparently.
- So, what are they talking about?
- There was like one where it
was like the girl's like 18
and the guy's 46 and has two kids.
And I'm like, that just
sounds like a bad idea.
- Like Ed and Rose.
- Yeah, it was like that and someone else.
What was the other one?
There was, like, these,
there was one of them.
I think it was like,
he was like a South African guy
and other one was like an American.
Like, she was like super
activist and stuff.
And like, he was just kind of
like the most laid back man
on earth.
He was like, "Yeah, yeah,
whatever, wherever."
And she was just like,
"I need you to know that I
care about these things."
And she was psychotic.
And, like, watching her, like,
behave around this guy was, like, awful.
I was just like, this is terrible.
This is awful.
Why is he doing this?
How much is he getting paid?
- Yeah, that's what I'm wondering.
Like, it's TLC.
- Are they getting paid?
Like, I need to know.
- It's TLC so they're definitely paid.
- Are you sure they're getting paid?
- They're getting paid pennies.
- Like, 'cause I feel like-
- I hope they're getting paid.
- Because if they're not getting paid,
I don't know why they're putting
up with half of this shit.
Like, it is-
- I'm pretty sure TLC pays all
of the people that they have-
- Are you sure?
- But yeah, but, like, I use
the word "paid" very loosely.
Like, they're probably getting
paid scraps for that shit.
- Yeah, it's just like, I'm watching this
and I'm like, how much
would you have to pay me?
- Because you know that
Rose, the Filipino girl,
she's like a YouTuber now.
- Yeah, I saw.
- So, it's just like, you
probably got paid shit all,
but hey, you got a YouTube
career now I guess.
I don't know.
You have a following.
- That's like a situation where,
if the other side is
just so goddamn awful,
it makes you look amazing.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Ed did her a solid.
- It's always weird for me
watching American reality TV show
versus British reality TV show
'cause I feel like British
reality TV show is, like,
so much more toned down than American.
Like, I think one of the thing
of British reality TV shows,
the peak that comes to
me is something like
"Come Dine With Me."
- That's pretty good.
Or like what's the other one
that that fuckin' guy does
where you just come up to him at a table
and he buys shit off
you for like 100 quid?
Antique Hunters or something?
- Oh, "Antiques Roadshow."
- "Antiques Roadshow."
- Is that it?
- I like that.
I like that show.
- Show's literally been
on the air for, like,
I don't know how long and
it's just fun to watch.
People just bring in some things.
"I'll give you fuckin' 20 quid for it."
- It's like the fuckin',
you know, like "Pawn Stars."
- But like legit.
- But like more legit than that.
- Yeah, "Come Dine With Me" is
probably the best British
reality TV show I think.
- I enjoy it.
One of my favorite trash
reality TV shows on,
I can't remember the name,
but the concept is they take
this couple who, you know,
doesn't have a lot of money,
but want to get married.
- It's like a-
- "Cheapest Weddings," right?
- Not "Cheapest Weddings."
- That's the Australian version.
- Is that the Australian version?
- They give them 10K to
sort out this wedding.
- Oh, it's like...
- And like, the bride has no control.
She doesn't know anything,
and it's all up to the guy.
- Aki's obsessed with that show.
- It was a BBC Three show.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- "Who Called the Bride?"
or something like that?
- Something like that.
- "Who Wants the Bride?"
Something like that.
- Something like that.
But it was such a good
concept in my opinion
'cause like 10K I feel like
is just the right amount
of money to be able to
make a wedding happen,
but not enough to make everything you want
out of a wedding happen.
- It's pretty genius.
- Yeah, it's genius.
And, like, making the guy do it as well.
- Yeah, I mean, you don't
need producers, right?
You just sit there and follow the guy.
If he does nothing,
that's fantastic content.
It's like-
- They must be fully aware of it too.
'Cause they always choose to use the 10K
in the worst fucking way imaginable.
- We should've done that
with Garnt's wedding.
(everyone laughs)
- Hey, Garnt, here's 10K.
Go for it, dude.
- The guys in the show,
the first thing they do
is like call up the crew.
- The boys.
- They call up their
boys, and they're like,
and then like the main guy
will be fucking clueless.
And that one friend who's like,
"I really don't think you
should hire inflatable dinosaurs
"for your wedding.
"That seems like a bad idea."
- "Nah, nah, I got this.
"This is my wedding."
- It's always like, there's always that,
there's either the guy who like,
there was never a guy who
got it like 100% right.
There was a guy who was like pretty close,
and it like did a modest attempt,
and then there was just the
other type of guy that was like,
"I'm gonna do fucking
Star Wars themed wedding.
"It's my wedding!"
- My favorite one is the one where, like,
the groom like decides to get
married in like a pig barn.
- Oh yes, I've seen this one.
- They deadass go to, like,
a farm with like fuckin' mud-
- It's like muddy, yeah.
- He's like, "But you love pigs."
- I think I saw one where the guy, like,
hosted the wedding in a cave,
like a proper, an actual cave.
- That's badass.
- I mean, that's badass, but then like,
he knew that the bride's
mum was claustrophobic.
(everyone laughs)
- How to get rid of the in-laws.
- So, the bride's mum actually
couldn't attend, like,
the wedding ceremony.
- Standing outside the cave.
- That's fuckin' big brain.
That's so big brain.
"So, my in-laws hate boats,
"so I decided let's get on a cruise."
- As someone who's, like,
planning a wedding now,
it's great for me 'cause I'm just like,
I see the stress that people-
- Giving a survey to,
like, Sydney's family.
"So what are your fears by the way?
"Spiders?"
- "What are you afraid of?"
- "We talkin' like zoos?"
- My favorite moment is always
when they try to pick the dress.
It's never, it's not even
like a little bit wrong.
It's always the complete opposite
of what the bride picked.
- It's literally like and one, two, three,
and have a breakdown, have a
mental breakdown right now.
Start crying, start telling
him the wedding's over.
That's literally how it.
This episode is sponsored by ExpressVPN.
- Guys, we talk about shitting
a lot on this podcast, right?
- We do, we do.
- We do admittedly, yes.
- [Garnt] Now don't you want to shit
with the privacy of the
bathroom door locked?
- Of course I do.
- Well, using the internet
without ExpressVPN is
like going to the bathroom
and not closing the door.
So, why would we want to do that?
- That just sounds barbaric,
and I will not stand for it.
- I'm being told that
internet service providers
like Comcast or Verizon know
every single website you visit.
- That's really interesting information
because I've also heard that
ISPs can sell this information
to ad companies and tech giants
who then use your data to target you.
- [Garnt] ExpressVPN creates
a secure encrypted tunnel
between your device and the internet,
so your online activity
can't be seen by anyone.
- It's as easy as closing
the bathroom door.
Simply fire up the app
and press one button.
And I use this all the time
when I'm watching anime
as certain websites don't
let you watch from Japan,
and trust me, it's fuckin' easy.
- What device do you use it on?
- Every single device I have.
My PC, my phone,
probably my refrigerator
soon when it gets installed.
- [Joey] Not only that,
but it's rated number one
by CNET, Wired, The Verge,
and other creditable sources.
And it's actually quite cheap per month.
- ExpressVPN has been
a game changer for me
because I cannot tell that
I'm even connected to a VPN.
There's no losses in speed whatsoever.
- So, what are you waiting for?
Secure your online activity today
by visiting ExpressVPN.com/TrashTaste.
That's ExpressVPN.com/TrashTaste.
- And you can get an
extra three months free.
- Go to ExpressVPN.com/TrashTaste.
Back to the episode.
I would, you know, even if I got, like,
paid on top of doing the wedding,
'cause I'm assuming the,
like, kind of the reason
why people apply for that show
is you get a free wedding.
- Yeah.
- But, like, man,
organizing a wedding seems
like one of the easiest
things to get wrong.
(Garnt laughs)
I thought about this-
- That's the most nervous laughter.
- I thought about this
and I was like, "Goddamn."
Just the like, 'cause you know, like,
you have friends, right?
But like not every friend you
want to come to your wedding,
right?
It must be so fucking
awkward deciding, like,
you're a good enough friend,
but like, I don't know
if you're like good
enough for the wedding.
- I can barely organize a boys' night out,
let alone a fucking wedding.
- 'Cause also, like, how
many friends do you have?
And like, where do you draw the line?
Who's close enough?
How do you decide?
Is it like a mutual thing?
You're like, "No, I don't like Ted."
- Wedding politics is
like definitely a thing.
Like, my cousin went through it as well.
And it's just,
there's a lot that goes
into a wedding that I, like,
I have no interest.
- Didn't foresee.
- I didn't obviously, it's, like,
trying to plan a wedding
yourself is hard enough,
trying to plan a wedding when
you're not in the country
and also during, like, COVID hit-
- Hard mode.
(everyone laughs)
- This is like not even like hard mode.
This is like Dark Souls no hit run.
Like, there's so many
things that can, like,
that can fuck up as well.
- I love how nowadays
whenever anything is like extremely hard,
the first thing you think
of is Dark Souls no hit.
Nothing's harder than that.
- I mean, it's stressful,
but it's rewarding.
- Yeah, it must be.
- I think.
- Is it, Garnt?
If Sydney's watching, yes, yes.
- It's rewarding until,
like, it will be rewarding once
it actually finishes, right?
And everything goes smoothly.
- I mean, like the planning parts,
some of it's better than the others.
Like, I remember, like, my
favorite moment so far has been
actually going to the venue
and just being like,
yeah, this is the place.
This is the place.
That's an amazing feeling.
Everything up to that, like,
searching through about 50
catalogs of possible places
and driving to about 10 different places,
and being like, "Do I
want to settle on this?
"I don't know.
"Can I see myself
getting married in a barn
"or a cave or whatever?"
- In Japan it's, like, crazy
how, like, fucking
seriously they take this.
- Oh, yeah.
- Oh, it's even, it's
like in Asia they're like,
we think there's like wedding
politics in Western weddings.
No, in Asia it's a fuckin' statement.
And I hate that.
I absolutely hate that 'cause-
- There's so many unspoken
rules in an Asian wedding.
- The amount that they must
spend on weddings here-
- Oh, it's nuts.
- It's insane.
- If you go to, like, any,
like, fancy hotel in Japan,
like, you just, 'cause you know,
if you go there for, like,
a lunch or something,
you'll see that, like, the
wedding planning rooms are
like full with people.
And like, those prices don't seem cheap.
They seem real expensive!
Like, 50K on a wedding, I'm like, what?
- Yeah, I went to one
of my friend's weddings
from university and he
did it in Japan in Tokyo,
and the inside of this venue looked
like a fuckin' mini Disneyland.
Like, there was, like, a castle
and, like, a fuckin' fountain
and this, like, massive
completely white church.
I'm like, how much money
did you spend on that?
- Like, what amount of
money is too much to spend
on a wedding?
I get that it's a special day.
but there has to be a limit
where like special day
is, like, ridiculous.
- Not to mention, there was
like 300 people at this wedding.
- Yeah, because like,
nobody knows 300 people.
I'm sorry.
I don't even know if I even have
that many friends on Facebook,
let alone at a wedding.
- Do you get, like, families asking like,
"Hey, can my like family
friend of a friend come?"
Do you get, like, that?
'Cause I feel like that, I'd be like, no.
Hell fuckin' no.
- In Japan, it's, like, the
wedding politics extends
to, like, you have to invite work people.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
'Cause it's all about face, right,
so, like, in Thailand, you
have to invite your family,
your family friends, your work colleagues,
like, basically everyone.
- I mean, close colleagues, yeah.
- If they're actual mates.
- I'm not inviting my boss.
- Another thing about Thai weddings is-
- Meilyne's like.
Shut up, Meilyne.
- Which is why, like,
me and Sydney decided
to have our wedding in the UK.
So, we didn't have to worry
about, you know, that side of-
- All that bullshit, yeah.
- But, like, it's a customary
in Thai weddings as well
that the groom has to give money,
has to give, like, a
certain amount of money
to the bride's, like, family.
- What?
- For the father to accept or something?
- What era are we in?
Are you buying her?
Is that like an extra step?
- "How much is your daughter?
"I give you two goats."
- Is there, like, an auction?
Like, what is this?
- I mean-
- That's, like, fuckin'
Russian, like, mother,
like, "I'll give you two goats."
- This feels like an extra
step to, like, auction.
You know?
- Yeah, I mean, it's something
that I don't agree with.
And I've seen, like, some
of my family members do it,
and I'm just like, yeah, I don't know.
I kind of don't agree with this.
- Is that where it comes from?
Like, where does that come from?
- Honestly, I have no idea.
- Does it come from some more sinister,
like way back-
- It must.
- It must've.
I mean, I'm not sure
how the custom started
because, you know, it's something that,
I've attended Thai weddings
and I've seen happen.
I've never kind of asked
where this came from.
I just kind of was just like,
yeah, I don't think I want to do that.
- "Did you buy Mom?"
(everyone laughs)
- "A cheap price."
- "I did it at a deal, son."
- "I mean, it's all bargained."
(everyone laughs)
- It's also, like, the same
customary where it's, like,
the bride's dad is expected
to pay for the wedding.
And I'm just like, no, that
shouldn't be the case either.
- Yeah.
- Like, it's,
to me a wedding there's so
many customaries to weddings
that revolve around money
that I just don't understand.
- I guess 'cause, like, maybe,
I mean that's pretty
common in the West still
that the other person-
- The bride-
- The bride's parents will pay.
I mean, it's understandable
when marriage used to
be way younger, like 21.
Like, I get it then 'cause
you don't have any money.
But now people are
getting married at what?
Like, 27, 30.
So, it's like, you know.
I mean, probably should
have your own money by then,
you know?
- Probably shouldn't be planning a wedding
if you're unemployed at 30.
(everyone laughs)
- Yeah, maybe.
Just dissing some people.
- I mean, just saying.
- I'm sorry for that guy
who just like, you know,
had, like, five children
and all of them ended up being daughters.
(everyone laughs)
"Fuck!
"Come on, son, son, son!
"Oh God!"
- It's like the, like, aging population,
like, pyramid thing where it's like,
"It won't bite you now.
"It'll bite you later."
(everyone laughs)
- Yeah, because isn't there, like,
I remember I saw like this,
I don't remember if it
was a "Vice" documentary
or some kind of documentary
on YouTube where, like,
I forgot which country it was,
somewhere in the Middle East where, like,
they still have the tradition
of, like, wife-napping.
- What?
- Where it's like, they, I
forgot which country it was.
But I remember I saw this documentary,
and there's this tradition,
"tradition,"
where guys, if they find a
girl that they find attractive
and they see as "wife material,"
some of them will actually,
like, deadass kidnap them,
like in broad daylight,
take them back to their parents' place,
and the girl is then forced
to get married to this guy.
- What is this?
Like, fuckin' real life Pokemon?
- This sounds like Runescape.
This sounds like Runescape.
- Yeah.
And like, traditionally
the girl can't decline it.
- Really?
- Yeah, so, like, she has to get married.
And there's all these,
and this documentary I saw is, like,
it's so fuckin' disturbing
'cause there's these girls
who are literally just breaking down
while they get the veil put
on top of them and shit.
And it's just, it's fucked.
I wish I could remember the
name of the documentary.
- Literally the "Trash
Taste" podcast is like,
"There was this thing.
"I don't remember though."
(everyone laughs)
- Just look it up.
If look up, like, "wife-napping"
I think it's called.
- "Trash Taste" podcast,
early onset Alzheimer's.
Just fucking forgetting,
we forget everything here.
We can't remember anything.
We're fucking useless.
- This thing I saw on the
internet I vaguely remember about,
but there's one detail I remember
that I want to talk about now
and just share it to the world.
It's fucked up.
- I remember perfect example
of that I think was the,
there was one episode we
were talking about, like,
how very rarely, like,
anime uses English, like,
songs in the openings and endings.
And we're bringing up all these titles,
and we're like, I'm sure there's
other ones we don't know.
All the titles are, like, "Jojo."
(everyone laughs)
"Hello?
"You know that one show
you're all obsessed about?"
- I just forget everything all the time.
- I feel like when you're put on the spot,
especially when you're put on the spot.
- And you're recording.
- And you're recording, it's just-
- Never take our word on anything.
That's just the golden rule.
Never take our word on anything.
- We are not liable for anything that we-
(everyone laughs)
You know what I don't forget though?
'Cause it happened to me right yesterday?
- What?
- I got stopped by the police.
- What do you mean?
- What did you do?
- I'm a criminal.
- What illegal activity-
- Being white!
I'm joking.
(everyone laughs)
- Being a minority for once.
- Wait, what did you do?
- Nothing.
I was, literally nothing.
(everyone laughs)
So like, I was literally, like,
okay, so I'm coming up the
escalator to, like, you know,
'cause in Japan you have to, like,
ding out of the gates, right?
So I'm coming up to the escalator
to go through the gates,
and there's like two pylons, two sets,
and so I'm coming up the escalator.
So, I'm gonna go forward, to go out,
and literally hiding behind
the pylon is a police officer.
And when I pass him,
I've got headphones on,
I got a, like, cap on,
so, like, maybe I look fuckin' dodgy.
I don't know.
But literally when I pass this guy,
I see like in my corner of my
eye this guy jump in action.
Just immediately come
up to me and stop me.
And I'm like, "Fuck.
"What have I done, dude?"
But I'm like, "What's wrong?"
And I'm like, ah, so I won't
say anything in Japanese.
I'll just translate it all.
He's like, "Oh, where are you going?"
And I'm like, "Just going home, you know.
"Just chilling out.
"Why, what's up?"
He's like, "Oh, really, cool, cool.
"Can I see your card?"
So you have, like, a
foreigners card, right?
- Which by law, you always
have to have this foreigner,
what's it called?
- Zairyu card.
- Yeah, yeah.
And he asked me if Japanese's okay.
I'm like, "Yeah, I can
speak a little bit."
And luckily like everything
he said I understood,
so it was good.
And he was like, "Oh, okay."
And by the way, like,
my train is in, like,
I think like four minutes,
so I'm like, "Come on, mate.
"Come on."
Like, "Keep it up, keep it up."
So, he looks at my card and it says like,
oh, I'm an entertainer.
And he's like, "Oh, cool, cool.
"What do you do?"
I'm like, oh, I say, "Seiyu"
which means like voice actor.
He's like, "Ah, seiyu."
And I'm like, "Yeah, yeah."
And then he's like, "Oh, sensei."
So, like, Japanese teacher.
And I'm like, what?
I literally just told you,
why would it be entertainer?
I'm just sitting there
like, "Oh no, no, no."
Like, "Seiyu, seiyu."
Like, commercials, games.
He's like, "Oh, games."
I'm like, "Yeah, yeah games."
He's like, "What games?"
And I was just like,
what do you want me to?
Like, you gonna look it up?
Like, what do you want?
So I'm like, "Oh, it's an English.
"It's an English."
And he's like, "Oh."
Deadass, right, he goes,
"Oh, do you play Apex?"
(everyone laughs)
No joke.
He's, like, 40, maybe 50.
Deadass asked me if I play Apex.
I'm just sitting here, like, laughing.
So I'm like, fuck.
(everyone laughs)
I shit you not I say,
"Yeah, I'm diamond rank."
He goes, (speaks Japanese)
Which means like, "Oh, you're strong."
I'm like, "Yeah, yeah, yeah."
Okay, like two minutes, two minutes.
My train's in two minutes.
And he's like, "Oh cool,
you're from the UK."
I'm like, "Yeah, yeah, from the UK."
So it's like, and then this
point, I feel like, ah, okay.
I'm kind of like, I know
he's not gonna, like-
- He's just making conversation.
- He's just talking to me.
- Sounds like he's just
looking for a friend right now.
- I don't know why he's talking to me?
He doesn't say why he stopped me.
He doesn't say anything like that.
- Maybe he was one of the Japanese dudes
you played Apex with.
- Maybe, maybe.
- He just looks at you, and he's like,
"This guy gives off gamer energy.
"I'ma stop him."
- "I wonder if that guy plays Apex.
"I'm gonna stop him and ask him."
And so, yeah, so I'm like,
"Yeah, I'm from the UK."
He asked where I'm from.
- So, he can speak good English then?
- No, no, it's all in Japanese.
- He can speak, he was-
- Luckily everything he
said, I either understood
or understood enough of what he's saying
to figure out what he's,
like, he said something
about something going to UK,
something, something marriage.
And I'm like, "Ah," and
I said like, honeymoon,
in like katakana, like, "Ah honeymoon."
He's like.
So, he told me that he went
to the UK and he loved it.
He said, "Okii Ben."
(everyone laughs)
- Okii Ben!
- He said he liked Big Ben,
and he liked Buckingham Palace.
He said, the Japanese
word for palace which is-
(Joey speaks Japanese)
- Yeah.
He said that something palace.
(Joey speaks Japanese)
- Yeah, he said, "Buckingham
(speaks Japanese)"
I'm like, I'm pretty sure
he's saying Buckingham Palace.
"Oh, it's beautiful.
"It's beautiful."
He's like, "Yeah, yeah, yeah."
- I can't get over Okii Ben.
- Okii Ben!
I was, like, laughing.
I'm like, I don't want to laugh though.
He's a police officer.
He'll be like, "Why are you laughing?"
- Because you guys know
what ben means, right?
- What?
- It means shit.
(everyone laughs)
So saying, "okii ben."
- I didn't know that.
- Is like deadass means "giant shit."
- I mean, it's pretty shit.
It's pretty shit.
- Big shit, big shit.
- It's the big shit.
- I thought he, 'cause I thought
the word for shit was unko?
- No, ben is another word for it, yeah.
- So, yeah, and then he
was just like, "Paris."
I'm like, "Oh yeah, you like wine?"
He was like, "Yeah, me
and my wife love wine."
I'm like, "Cool, cool, I like wine too."
And he's like, "All right,
yeah, you can go now."
And I'm like, "Thanks man.
"Thanks for making me
miss my fucking train."
(everyone laughs)
I had to wait 10 minutes for the next one.
- So you deadass just bonded
with a police officer over Apex.
- Yeah, luckily it was nice,
but like, it's pretty, like, alerting
when you first stop you,
and I'm like, why are you stopping me?
Why are you stopping me?
And then someone told
me, they were like, yeah,
apparently there's, like,
some police officers have quotas of, like,
people they have to stop.
- Oh really?
- Makes sense.
They've just got so
little work to do here.
- And they're normally told to-
- I guess they're getting
paid to do something.
- This is, like, the least, like,
xenophobic way of, like, saying this.
But I've been told, I
don't know if this is true,
some police officers are
told to stop foreigners
to practice their English.
- I mean, that makes sense.
- That makes sense.
- But it feels wrong.
Like, if that happened in another country,
it'd be like, that's fucked
up, that's not right.
But I mean, you know-
- At least they're nice
about it though, right?
- Yeah, I just don't like
that they asked, like, my ID.
I don't know something
about that feels weird.
- I guess they-
- Like, check my card.
- I think because they're obligated to.
- I think they have to do that, right.
'Cause if there's-
- Feels threatening when
someone asks your ID.
- I mean, there's never a way
where a policeman asks for your ID,
and you don't at least sweat a little.
- Yeah, I'm like (breathes heavily)
- You do the like audible swallow.
- This is literally like
white guy gets, like,
discriminated first time in his life POV.
This is the story, right?
- "So this is what it feels
like to be a minority."
- Shit.
This is fucked up.
(everyone laughs)
I'm kidding.
I know it's fucking bad.
But like, yeah, I mean,
it's happened a few times,
but it was 'cause it
happened at like 10:00 PM.
I was like, you know,
for some reason when it happens at night,
it feels like way more like whoa.
And I'm like, why aren't
you stopping anyone else?
I'm the only non-Japanese here.
- Dude, you shouldn't have told
this story on "Trash Taste."
You could have easily made a
"My first racist experience
in Japan" type of video.
- I'll do it on a live stream.
So, the clip can come out before this.
- Good idea, good idea.
Big brain.
- I just like, I just
started cracking up so much
when he asked me if I played Apex.
I was like, oh my God.
I was like, you can't make this shit up.
Like, I knew when I was
gonna tell the story,
people are gonna be
like, "That's bullshit."
No, it actually,
I wish I fucking recorded.
- This like, yeah, and everyone applauded.
- I was like, this is too unreal
that he literally just
asked me if I play Apex.
But I literally, like, don't
shut up about to everyone.
But it's really popular in Japan.
- It's massive in Japan.
- What are, like, the
biggest games in Japan?
- What genre of games?
Like, what?
In first person shooters?
I think it's, like, Apex right now.
- Like, 'cause are online
games big in Japan even?
- Yeah, yeah, there's a huge scene for it.
- Apex right now is massive because,
because shockingly because of
VTubers that are playing it.
- It was popular before that.
- Yeah, but the VTubers
propelled the fuck out of it.
- Yeah, because like
when we moved to Japan,
I think is when-
- PubG was big, right?
- PubG was big, but I think
Apex either just released
or released like a while back,
and they were doing a huge push for it
because the month where he moved here,
every single ad I got was Apex Legends.
- Really?
- In Japan, yeah.
Everything was.
And I thought, wow, that's kind of weird
'cause it's kinda like a
dead game in, like, the West
or at least it was.
I feel like it flip flops in
whether it's popular or not.
- What even counts as a
dead game anymore, right?
- Overwatch I'd say.
That's 'cause Overwatch 2's coming out,
so they just like abandoned.
- Right.
- But like, you know,
I mean not a dead game,
but like not in, like,
the public discourse is
what I would consider like,
when people say "dead game,"
I think that's what they mean.
Like, it's not like no one plays it.
- The main population is
talking about it or not, right?
- Yeah, like it's not like you, you know,
you're not expected to have
some general knowledge about it.
- You're not expected to
have a police officer come up
to you and say, "Do you play Overwatch?"
And you're like, "Dead game."
- "Who do you main?
"Who's your Overwatch main?"
- I'm gonna sound like such
a fucking boomer right now.
Like, what even are the
popular games right now?
(Joey laughs)
'Cause like when I think-
- No, I feel that.
- When I think popular
game, I think, you know,
whatever the fad is right now,
like Among Us and Fall Guys.
- Well I think, after the
Among Us kind of like settled,
it definitely became a bit more variety.
Like, tends to be quite a lot.
Like, Valheim is picking up steam,
which is kind of like a
re-imagining of Runescape almost.
- All I've heard Valheim is is just, like,
Minecraft but better graphics.
- I heard Runescape mixed with Minecraft.
- Oh really?
- Apex is obviously had
a really big resurgence.
Really good numbers.
Like, a lot of big streamers
are getting back into it.
I think Valorant is
still doing pretty well.
Leagues, obviously Leagues.
- League's just always up there.
- I think CS Go is still the same thing
where it's always been,
like kind of like, you know,
the scrappy little underdog.
- Because I think the thing is, like,
I look at the top watched games on Twitch,
and they're normally, like, the games
that I just never end up playing.
So, I don't actually,
I never actually know
what everyone ends up playing
or what's kind of popular right now.
- We haven't had any
massive games recently.
After Among Us we haven't
really had anything
that's stolen the
spotlight, I don't think.
I could be wrong.
I think the last time I spoke about games,
I got things very wrong.
People gave me shit, and
that's fair enough, go ahead.
- I feel like the whole
idea of, like, you know,
like, the most popular game
nowadays is a little bit blurred
just because, like, anyone
can play anything now.
- I feel like it's like
there's gonna be the top games.
Like, chess has had a
big resurgence obviously.
Bloons Tower Defense 6,
man, I'm telling you, man,
I'm just kidding.
- It's coming.
- Everyone's playing it, man.
- I'm stepping in before it gets big.
- Fortnite obviously is just Fortnite.
I don't know.
Like, I feel like a lot of games are
just kind of like settled.
We haven't really had
anything that's shaken up.
- Yeah, I mean, I remember
for the longest time
when the League community
where everyone was just like,
"Yo, League's dying.
"League's dying."
- It's never gonna die.
- Yeah, it's never gonna die.
It plateaued.
But I feel like there's a difference
between something plateauing
and something kind of, like-
- Also the League
viewership has been, like,
pretty consistent.
- Just because it plateaus
doesn't mean it's,
you know, dying.
- No, no, no.
I mean, League is still like, you know,
you can still easily support
a billion dollar company
with the amount of people
playing it, so you know.
But it's like, in public
discourse, right, and all.
- I usually chalk up to whether
a game is popular if like-
- Minecraft as well.
- Like, the younger
generation are playing it.
- True.
- Like, if you go to
like a primary school,
and they're talking about Apex
and Fortnite and Minecraft
then it's like, okay, this is
like the big games right now.
- Yeah, it's funny, man.
I mean, my mom was telling me,
she works in a primary school,
she's telling me like one
kid got, like, really bullied
because he was, like, bad at Fortnite.
- No, wasn't there a, there was a story-
- Skin as well.
- Yeah, there was a story in
Japan where a kid got bullied
because he had the
default skin in Fortnite.
(everyone laughs)
- Serves him right.
- Wow.
- I mean, I think we've
talked about this before,
but I've heard the same story as well.
- But like, I think
Minecraft is definitely
probably the biggest.
- I'd say Minecraft is still the biggest.
- Minecraft's just a
juggernaut at this point.
- Since the last stream, I've been like,
ooh, should I play Minecraft?
- Play Minecraft, dude!
- Should I play Minecraft?
- It's deadass so fun.
It's so relaxing.
- If we all play Minecraft,
you guys gotta try Apex.
We should do that.
We should do, like, a game
cultural cross-pollination.
- Cross-pollination.
- We should do that.
Come on.
That's what the people want, Garnt.
- You're just never gonna
give up on this, are you?
- 'Cause I know if you guys try
it, you'll have a good time.
I reckon you guys will enjoy it.
- Will we?
- Yeah, I think you will.
- I think every person
who offered me an FPS
game said the same thing.
- 'Cause this is with
the boys, so you know.
- I heard it about Fortnite.
I heard it about Overwatch.
I've already talked about this.
- We'll give it a shot.
We'll give it a shot.
We'll try it, guys.
Don't worry.
I'll convince them
- So, I guess switching gears.
Did you guys hear about
this, like, deepfake story
that happened, I think today or yesterday?
- Yesterday for us,
but probably like three
weeks for the audience.
- Yeah, three weeks for the audience.
- So, facts may come out and
we could be totally wrong.
- I have not.
- With deepfake becoming such a,
like, a bigger thing now,
so I can't,
we're gonna go back to this!
(everyone laughs)
I can't remember every
detail of the story,
but I think the main gist of it was
there was this mom and she had a daughter
who was on the cheerleading squad.
- Can we get Meilyne to check the story
while we're talking about it?
Just Google deepfake news.
It'll be, like, the top story.
- So, I believe there was
a mum who had a daughter
who was on the cheerleading squad.
And there were other girls
on that cheerleading squad,
and for some reason she wanted the,
she wanted to kick these
other girls off of the squad.
So, what she did is she
made some deepfakes, like,
of the other girls.
- Like, smoking, drinking-
- Yeah, like smoking, drinking,
doing like bad illegal
activities or whatever.
And I think threatening them with it.
I can't remember if she threatened them
or she sent them straight to-
- I'm not sure how she did
it, but I think they saw it.
And the reason why it
got even found out was
because they took it to the police.
Like, a few of them went to the police.
- Yeah, and how she got found out was
she used the fake number.
She used like this internet service
that gave her a fake number,
but that didn't hide her IP address.
And that's the only
reason she got found out.
- Cut to the sponsor.
(everyone laughs)
- This episode is sponsored by (laughs)
- You know, I don't think
she would've got caught
if she was sponsored by (laughs)
I don't think our sponsor
would be very happy.
- No.
That's why we're not
gonna mention any names.
- Yeah, but I mean, I saw
it, and I'm just like,
I can't believe it actually took this long
for something like this to happen.
- You know what the most
unbelievable part of the story is?
There's a mom out there
that's tech savvy enough.
- That's what I thought.
- I don't even think my mum knows
what a fuckin' deepfake is, let alone,
she doesn't even know how to
search for files on Windows.
I'm actually impressed her mum
knew how to make a deepfake.
What?
- I'm impressed that mum
knew how to do a deepfake,
but I'm even more like,
because, okay, I'm not sure
if any of this is confirmed.
So, I'm gonna put out a disclaimer that-
- We could be totally wrong.
Please check the story.
- Do your own research.
- By the time this comes out.
All right
- I'll check the story while-
- By the time this comes out,
everything might be confirmed.
This might all have been,
like, false information
or it might've just been, like, claims.
But at the time of recording,
we don't know if it's real or not.
But these are what the allegations are.
And the allegation was that she did this
because the daughters on
the cheerleading squad.
She stopped hanging out with her daughter.
And so she wanted to get them
kicked off because of that.
And I'm just thinking
if someone's this petty to be this crazy.
- How dare you not be
friends with my daughter.
- How does she manage to
figure out how to do deepfakes?
- She also sent them anonymous
messages telling them to,
that they should, you know,
end their own lives as well
to these kids.
- The mum did that?
- The mum did that.
- What the fuck?
- This fucking, how,
this is some fucking-
- Some people are not
supposed to be parents.
- So like cartoon villainous.
Like, it's so absurd that
someone can be this fucked.
Oh my God.
- Yeah.
But I mean, I saw that,
and I'm just thinking,
my first thought was one, I'm surprised
that it took this long for
something like this to happen.
- This mugshot looks like
she's tore someone's face off.
- Oh my God!
- She looks like a Disney villain.
- Yeah, Maleficent just
ripped someone's face off
and stitched it.
I shouldn't say that.
It's probably going too far, isn't it?
Actually no, fuck you!
You deserve it!
(everyone laughs)
Telling kids to, what?
- That actually looks like she's wearing
someone else's face.
- Oh my God.
You know what's more
concerning about that?
That was someone's parent.
Holy fuck.
Imagine being raised by someone like that.
That kid's gonna be fucked.
God.
- But apparently the kid knew nothing.
Like, the mum did this
without telling the kid.
She did this by herself.
- How would you even tell the kid?
Like, "Are you cool with this, kid?"
"No, I'm not!
"Mum, what's wrong with you?"
- There's replying back to a nasty tweet
and then there's creating deepfakes.
- "Please don't tell my schoolmates
"to go kill themselves and
make deepfakes of them."
- When I would tell my mum
that I was being bullied,
she wasn't thrilled about it,
but she was like, you know,
"I'm not happy about this.
"I'll put in a word to the teacher
"but you're on your own kid.
"This is your problem."
- It's like, "I can't deal with this shit.
"I don't even know what's going on."
- Like, I mean, fucking hell.
- That's scary.
- I mean, just so many parts
of the story is actually insane
that this could happen.
It is literally like a horror movie plot.
- [Joey] It is.
- What?
- This is kinda like,
it's almost too cartoony
to be a "Black Mirror" episode.
- It is, it is.
It's so like,
if this was a "Black Mirror" episode,
you'd be like, "Yeah,
twist's really predictable.
"Really over the top."
- Like B grade horror film.
- The mom's kind of an
unbelievable villain here.
She could have used more
character development,
more motivation.
No, this is reality.
But what scares me is that, like,
what does this mean for the
future of deepfakes now?
Because like this week especially,
this new app's come up where
it's gotten really easy
to deep fake, you know.
Deepfake, you know, use it for memes,
use it for harmless memes
to make people sing fucking Baka Mitai.
- You know, we're used to people doing
fucking terrible Photoshops
or doing stuff like that.
So, if someone sent me a video of me doing
something I clearly didn't
do or never ever did,
I'd be like, "I don't really give a fuck.
"It's fake."
And I'll say it's fake,
and that'll probably be the end of it.
But to someone who's never
really had anything online
or any kind of like, you know,
posted anything about themselves
outside of their personal Facebook,
I can see why receiving a video
that looks like you doing something
that you didn't do could
be fucking terrible.
- Yeah.
- You would think that,
wow, people are really
going to believe this,
even though, you know, realistically
they're probably not going to
if you explain that it's fake.
- Yeah, I mean, it's gotten
to a point where like,
for people like us especially
where we show our faces
on camera pretty often,
it wouldn't be hard to
make a convincing deep fake
with, you know, us coming on
camera literally every week.
- I think we all agree on this
that you do not have permission
to make any deepfakes of us
and we don't condone any of
them, by the way, just saying.
You're legally not allowed to do that.
- I mean, is there anything
legal that's you know, that-
- Yeah, you can't, you're not like,
I think legally speaking,
you can't like just do that.
Depending on what jurisdiction you're in.
I remember Tom Scott did a video about it.
I think the laws around it are a bit iffy
and obviously stuff
like this always takes-
- It's such a new thing.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's a really new thing.
'Cause like, you know, I've seen, like,
the Baka Mitai deepfakes.
I'm just like, you know, this
is a funny meme or whatever.
But then I don't know how I
would feel if I saw the, like,
you know, the KSI Ainsley
Harriott deepfake 'cause-
- That's so good though.
- That's so good.
It's funny as fuck, but then-
- Also so worrying.
- Something at the back of my mind
which makes me, like,
that's fucking worrying
how good it is.
And I'm glad it's been
used as a funny meme.
But my God, if I saw my face
on somebody else like that,
I would just think, damn,
I'm glad this is being
used for a funny meme,
but this could be used for
something that's really-
- Luckily right now as many
deepfake things are being made,
there's just as many
things that are detecting
if deepfakes have been made.
Like, programs that are
being written to detect them.
So, right now it's like, a
lot of softwares will detect
when it is a deepfake.
But whether it will get
to the point in the future
that there is-
- Do you think like it's
only a matter of time
before we get our first
deepfake cancellation?
- No, I think we're
quite far away from that.
I think they're still too rough
and the technology isn't there yet,
but I think it's possible
within like 10 years.
- I've seen some deepfakes
that are really fucking convincing though.
- But, like, the videos are, like,
always in like 480p max.
- But that's kind of the
video you would expect for,
I don't know, like the kind of
phone quality expose videos.
They're never like 720p 4K.
- It's always like fuckin'
PlayStation eye camera quality.
- But I think the easier
it gets to cancel someone
from a deepfake, the less
canceling will happen
'cause everyone will be
like, "It's a deepfake.
"Is it a deep fake?"
Or everyone's defense is
gonna be, "It's a deepfake."
- Yeah.
- Right.
But, like, how -
- "That video of me punching a baby?
"Deepfake."
(everyone laughs)
- How long until the
deepfake argument is going
to be legitimate?
- I mean, the moment that
you can cancel someone
for a deepfake is when that
argument would come valid.
'Cause they'll be like, "Oh,
well you saw that deepfake.
"Yeah, it was deepfake."
- "It's a really good deepfake.
"Looks so real!
"Oh my God, I can't believe it myself."
- Our world's going to
become a lot more messy
when it gets there unfortunately.
But you know.
- Yeah, I mean, what's scary
is that there's nothing
to stop the technology being out there.
But I mean, I guess you can
argue this for a lot of things.
'Cause I remember when, you
know, 3D printers became a thing
and then-
- Well, you can still 3D print guns.
- Yeah, you can still 3D print guns.
- You shouldn't, but you can.
- You shouldn't, and I
believe it's illegal, right?
- Well, it's most-
- The laws around it
are real weird I think.
- I think what it is is
that there's most 3D
printing machines can detect
if it's, like, the blueprint
of a gun or firearm
or something and just not-
- Well it's like a Photoshop.
If you put a picture
of the dollar bill in,
it won't let you do anything to it.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It'll, like, stop you.
- Oh really?
I had no idea.
- Yeah, so they don't
want you to Photoshop it
to like try and like, you know,
because the software is so powerful.
Photoshop is-
- Print out free money, yeah.
- Photoshop is a really powerful tool,
and the stuff that they
constantly adding to it,
it's just adding to the
repertoire of how strong it is.
And it's like very concerning.
But then again, you know, it's like
when Photoshop first started as well,
like we were all like,
"Oh my God, people are
gonna be like, it's crazy.
"Everyone's gonna start getting canceled
"or they're gonna be,
"people are gonna put
Nicholas Cage in orgies."
Although that's,
that's not unrealistic.
(everyone laughs)
- Bad example.
- I can't remember there being a case
where someone got in trouble
for a Photoshop picture.
Like, a big story.
Like, because normally, you know,
a picture at least, you know,
there needs to be a lot more context
behind why the picture exists
and without reasonable context of
why the picture would exist,
people aren't really gonna believe it.
I feel like it's probably
gonna be the same for a video.
Like, if there's a video
of like, I don't know,
like Robert Downey Jr. just like I said,
like, punching a kid in
like a park or something,
it's gonna be like, well,
one why is Robert Downey Jr.
in a park?
Why is he playing basketball
with a kid then punching him?
The context is gonna be needed.
Like, there's gonna be so many questions
that are gonna need to be answered
before you take a video seriously.
- But, like, how long until
you do run into like that,
you know, perfect
situation where it's like,
oh, the story is there,
the narrative is there,
everything lines up.
The only difference is that
Robert Downey Jr. didn't
actually punch the kid.
But I can make him punch the kid.
- It was a hoax.
- I mean, fuckin' fake news
articles are bad enough already,
you know, with how, you know,
there are fucking
anti-vaxxers and flat earthers
and just things that have been enabled
because it's so easy
to stay in your bubble
and really like strengthen
your own argument and your own-
- It's a worrying time.
I don't know.
- It is definitely a worrying time.
- But I don't let it get to me.
I'm trying to enjoy life, you know.
- I'm just trying to live my best life.
- The world may be ending, but
I'm gonna have a good time.
- I'ma still laugh at these memes.
(everyone laughs)
- I care about what I need to care about.
No more.
That's kinda how I like to do it.
Like, I just think that
after a certain point
if you just start
worrying about everything,
you're just gonna be fucking miserable.
And like, I think obviously, you know,
when it comes to like, you know,
you're voting on your politician,
yeah, I think you should care about that
and that should matter.
But like beyond that, do
I care if a news presenter
in the US says like
something fucking abhorrent?
I'm like, no, honestly
it's not really my problem,
and I don't really give a fuck.
Like, maybe that's, I don't know.
Is that, like, elitist to think that?
- I think it's just-
- Outside of my like, like,
you know, I don't know.
To me like stuff that goes on
in the US sometimes I'm like,
"That's honestly not my problem."
Like, is that bad?
Like, some people say
that's like a prejudice
or ignorant mindset.
Like, I have the luxury.
- It depends on the context, right?
Because the problem is that the problem
with that argument I feel is
that there's no way a human can care
about absolutely everything.
So, at some point you're
going to have to pick
and choose what you care about.
Otherwise, one, you're probably
gonna be a miserable fuck.
And two, you're gonna wake up
and you're just gonna be exhausted
and not gonna be able to
do anything in the day
because you just feel flooded.
And I feel flooded enough
with my own social media right now.
And this is me, like,
where social media is so
intertwined with our jobs.
So, I see this stuff and I'm just like,
I can't care about this.
- I'm pretty sure that's how
people become nihilists, right?
They're just like, they
look at the world as like,
"Oh, the world is shit.
"I guess nothing matters anymore."
- I mean, it feels like it's
just been so much, like,
heavier as well ever since
the pandemic as well.
'Cause you're just trying
to like get by, you know?
Life's already difficult enough
and then shit's going on,
and you're like, fuck, man.
Like, I'm literally
just trying to be happy
for like 10 seconds here.
Can I have this?
- Yeah, I kind of feel a
bit jealous of our parents
when they only had to care about the shit
that was happening around them.
Now I have to care about shit
that's happening halfway across the world.
- Like, when I see like, you know,
my parents are gonna get fuckin' furious
that they changed the bin
size of, like, the council
by like 10% lower they're like,
"Oh my God, this is unreasonable."
You know?
And like, I just miss the days
where I could give a fuck
about stupid like that.
Now I've got to worry
about like, literally like,
cultural ending stuff.
- Shit that has nothing to do
with you, right?
- It's just like, I don't know, man.
Like, I want to care about everything,
and I want to give, like,
people who are fighting
for like legitimate, like,
good fights, I want to help them out.
But at the same time, it's like,
there's so much fucking shit going on.
And obviously the internet's
obviously made all the
information even more accessible,
so there's so many more
things to care about.
Like, all right checking
up on global warming.
Don't waste too much food.
What's going on over here?
What's the, there's a civil
war going on in this country
and like atrocities happening.
How do I, like, legitimately,
like, give my energy-
- You're literally just
explaining how to live.
That's just life, isn't it?
- Yeah, and like, I don't want to be like,
"Global warming is more important
"than people dying in this country."
You know what I mean?
Where do you draw the line
of where to start caring?
- I mean, I think you can, like,
pick and choose what you care about,
but it's the difference
between being publicly open
about that stuff, right?
- I mean, I wouldn't say I
don't care about something
as much or, like, oh my God,
this is so tough to talk about.
- It is.
- It makes you sound like an asshole
if you say you don't
give a fuck about, like,
Meilyne, what do you think?
You're our manager.
Will you make sure we don't get canceled?
- Are we gonna get
canceled for this, Meilyne?
But no, no.
But no, I totally understand
because I feel like
that's just part of being human.
And you know, there's gonna be people
that, you know, make the argument,
well, you're privileged enough
that you don't have to care about it.
But, I would argue that surely,
surely you also can't care
about every single issue
happening in the world
'cause you feel strongly
about this one issue
because it definitely affects
you and I understand that,
but surely that means that
you can't put the energy
into caring about another issue.
- I don't think there's any
person out there living any type
of life, like, you know,
prejudice or not prejudice,
privileged or not,
who can deadass be in a
position where it's like,
right now everything in the
world I need to worry about
because it's important to me.
Like, it doesn't matter who you are.
Like, there's gonna be one piece of news
where you're just like, "That
has nothing to do with me."
- Something that resonates with you,
that you like really believe in
and that you fight
towards like helping that,
like I'm down with that, man.
- Yeah.
At least you're fighting
towards something.
That's better than someone just getting up
in the morning being like,
"I don't care about any of this shit."
- Yeah, I mean, like, it's,
it doesn't really bother me much
when people get like
angry about, you know,
"Oh my God, you don't care about this."
But I hate people who are like,
"You don't care enough
about this specific thing."
Like, "You should be so
angry about this thing."
And I'm like, man, I am
literally just trying to get by.
- What dictates like the
quantitative worth of
how much you care about something?
- There's always some
people who are willing
to get, like, outraged and, like,
really light a fire up their
ass for something, you know?
And like, you know, obviously
we need people like that.
- Yeah, of course.
- Otherwise shit doesn't get done.
- You can't expect
everyone to be like that.
- Yeah, but then I hate it
when I see people, like,
blackmailing other people being
like, "You should care more.
"You should care so much more about this."
- Because the problem with the argument is
that there's no way to
frame it without the person
who, you know, cares less about the topic.
There's no way to frame the argument
without making them, like, look good
because it's just, okay,
you don't care about it.
Therefore you are the asshole
because you don't care
about this important issue.
And I feel like, can we just
accept that we are all human?
You know?
We are all just trying to get by.
Everyone has different issues.
Some matter more than others,
but it's a lack of empathy.
You know, we,
in order to empathize with your problem,
you at least have to give us
some empathy as well, you know?
And, I feel like
there's just, like, a lack
of empathy in that sense
in that kind of argument.
- I'd like to think if I'm
being ignorant on any of this,
that, you know, it won't result in fuckin'
"let's cancel the boys"
but just let me know down below.
I will read the comments.
So, if I am missing any big point here
or I'm being ignorant,
please do let me know
'cause I would like to change my mindset.
- I don't think it's ignorance personally.
I think it's just like being honest.
- I mean, I'm exactly the same.
I try to keep as open-minded
as possible about everything,
and I've, you know, I've
definitely changed my viewpoints
on certain topics thanks
to what people have said
and what's been discussed.
- There was one person who,
'cause I think someone
tweeted at me and was like,
"Connor, you shouldn't
say the word crackhead
"as like a descriptive word.
"It's a bad word."
'Cause it apparently has to
do with a lot of, you know,
like racial stereotyping back
in the war on drugs in America
and stuff and it's used
as a derogatory term.
So, I just stopped saying it.
That was just 'cause someone
tweeted at me saying,
"stop saying it."
And I was like, well I
don't really need this word.
Like, you know, 'cause I
said it a lot on the podcast,
and you know, I realized
afterwards I'm like, yeah,
I mean, there's like way
better ways to describe that,
that feeling I was trying to
get across without using that.
And I'm like, yeah, I don't
really need to use that word.
I haven't said it since on
like podcast or anything.
So, I'm like, oh, I haven't said it ever
and I just don't feel the need to,
and I'm like, cool, thanks for
letting me know, commenter.
Like, if I have a bad habit, let me know.
I'll try and get rid of it.
If you're like, "Connor, you're fat."
Fuck you.
I'm working on it.
(everyone laughs)
Other things, okay.
- The ones I hate the most are,
"Connor, you got fatter."
It's like, wow, thanks.
(everyone laughs)
- That's always rough 'cause
that's like, oh my God, yeah.
I just feel bad for
people in that situation.
It's rough.
Comments be brutal sometimes.
Comments really do pick
apart like everything.
But it's cool though because
sometimes you miss something.
- Yeah, exactly.
I feel like having a good
balance is the healthy thing
because you have to find this balance
between knowing that you
can't please everyone
and finding a balance between, okay,
this person's making a legitimate point.
I can change my behavior
because, you know,
they're making a sound argument
and I completely understand.
- The comment section for the yes-men is
just kind of boring, isn't it?
- You know, people have that, you know,
whenever I read comments
about "Trash Taste"
it'll be like, "Oh, I fucking hate Joey,"
or "I fucking hate Connor."
And I'm like, well, I mean, I get it.
'Cause it's like, I guess
we're like characters.
- It's all good, dude.
- You have your favorite.
I get it.
- If you got your favorite,
it's all good, dude.
- Yeah, I don't know.
But then sometimes they go a
little too far with it, like,
"Man, I wish Connor would just
fuckin' quit the podcast."
- Oh, sorry, that's not
gonna happen any time soon.
- It's not gonna happen.
But like, if it did, do you
think everyone wants that?
I don't know.
- There are some that are just like,
"Man, I wish Connor would
just deck Garnt in the face."
(everyone laughs)
Or other way around.
- I will off camera.
- I'm just like, wow,
is this how friends act?
At least wait 'til the
"Trash Taste" special
where we decide to have a
boxing match or something.
Not that we have anything planned.
- Boxing special?
- Boxing match confirmed?
Confirmed?
- I'd actually unironically love to be
in like a YouTuber boxing match
'cause I just think like, one,
Meilyne's like getting ideas right now.
That multi-million dollar idea.
I wish I could bring in multi-million.
I don't know.
'Cause like, one, you
get an excuse to train.
You can probably hire a
personal coach, you know?
I'd probably get in mad shape for that.
And it'd probably be fun.
I'd play the villain.
I'd love that.
That'd be so much fun.
But who would I fight though?
You know, that's the thing.
I haven't got any enemies,
so I should start beef with someone else.
- Stop flexing.
- What?
Is not having enemies like
something to brag about?
Like, "Man, Connor, doesn't hate anyone."
- I mean, I didn't even ask
for enemies and I have enemies.
(everyone laughs)
- I mean, enemy's a very strong word.
- There's probably some
people who dislike me,
but, like, I don't have any like open beef
with anyone on YouTube.
I mean, I don't really
fuckin' do anything.
I just kinda just do my own thing.
- I mean, there's a difference
between having YouTuber beef
and having actual real beef
where you have a big problem with someone.
- What's like, what would you categorize
like the KSI Logan Paul stuff?
Just pure YouTube beef?
- That has to be YouTube beef, right?
It was so over the top.
- I mean, I don't like-
- I think they hated each other,
and I think along the
way they started liking-
- I'm pretty sure it
started as legitimate beef.
And then they were like, "Hold on, bro.
"We can make money off this."
- Tens of millions.
Hold on, hold the phone.
- I mean, I feel like the line is blurred
where you have a financial
incentive to have beef.
(everyone laughs)
If they're just like shit talking-
- I can see the light bulb, like,
over Meilyne's head right now
just like lighting up, bro.
- She's like, she has
a POG face right now.
- They made like over like what?
20, $30 million each?
- Something like that.
- 'Cause it's not actually beef,
like personal beef about
anything that really matters.
Like, no one told one of their
moms to go fuck themselves
or like, you know?
- Yeah, the insults were,
the fuckin' pre-match like beef, like,
shit talking things were the best part
of the boxing matches.
They were so bad at
talking shit to each other.
- It was like wrestling levels.
- Way worse.
- No, no, wrestling has good shit talking.
- I've seen some wrestling beef
like talking where I'm like-
- Kindergarten insults.
"Like, my dad works for Microsoft."
"Well, my dad works for Sony."
- "My dad is Nintendo."
- "My dad knows Shigeru Miyamoto."
It's like what?
- "Well my dad is Shigeru Miyamoto."
- "My dad's Goku."
(everyone laughs)
- Just like, yeah, watching,
and if you didn't give a about
any of the YouTube boxing,
it was quite entertaining as much as-
- It was entertaining to watch.
- I paid for the
pay-per-view cause I'm like,
you know what?
If he can make this a thing on
YouTube, I'm more than happy.
- I paid for it because I'm
just like, you know what?
You are making entertainment.
I fuckin' get that.
I'm watching a clown fiesta,
and I'm paying to watch the circus,
but I'll pay to watch the circus.
- I want more of this.
I think this is great for YouTube.
And also for boxing, it did like wonders.
And it was like-
- It's like the Renaissance of boxing.
- For the people in our age group.
- For people who didn't care about it.
- My dad loves boxing.
And then my dad's age bracket love boxing.
They love it.
But like, you know, under
30 and I think mid thirties,
they don't fuckin' give
a shit about boxing.
A lot of people don't.
I mean, I'm sure there's
a good segment of people
who probably love boxing
and MMA and all that.
But it wasn't like nearly as popular
as it used to be with
our age group, at least.
- 'Cause boxing was like, you know,
some of the most classic moments
in sports are boxing matches,
like anything like "Rumble in the Jungle,"
you know. anything with Muhammad Ali.
- Iconic.
- Fuckin' iconic to this day.
And you know, I grew up in an era
where I didn't even watch any
boxing match, I don't think.
I didn't watch boxing matches.
- I don't think I've ever sat down
and watched a boxing match in my life.
- I watched 'cause my
dad loved watching it,
and he'd be like, "Man, this
guy is fighting this guy
"for the world heavyweight."
And I'm like, "Who are these people?"
- 'Cause if you're a kid and
your parents weren't into it
then how the fuck can you afford
to watch the pay-per-view?
Like, there's no way you could watch it.
And it's always in American time.
So, it's always at like 3:00 AM.
- And you had to pay for like Sky,
which was already like 40 pounds a month,
and you pay an extra 20 pounds on top
to get the pay-per-view.
It was just, yeah, it was-
- [Joey] Crazy.
- Yeah, I mean, I don't know.
It's like, what do you
think about the whole,
I don't know if this is
changing gears too fast,
but what do you think
about the whole thing
where everyone's like, man,
they're ruining like boxing
by bringing in these influencers to it?
'Cause it's happened with chess as well.
- By bringing in these,
like, non-traditional-
- Like, you bring in, like,
you know, you kind of,
I guess the way they would argue is, like,
you're diluting, like, the sport.
- I don't understand how putting more eyes
onto a sport ruins it.
Because the whole point of
keeping a sport alive is
that a sport is kept alive
by how many viewers watch it.
- I mean, there's a side of
it where I can understand,
like, you know, for chess, like,
at least, you know what,
if you start at age 12,
and then you're like 30 now.
You're a Grandmaster.
You've literally been playing
your whole life for chess.
You're about to, like,
this is your time to shine.
And then fuckin' PogChamps
has like, you know,
20, 30 times more viewers than
anything you ever will get.
I could understand why they're mad.
- That just sounds like
a villain protagonist
to some sports anime.
- Yes, I understand why-
- A bit of backstory to some sports anime.
- It's super easy to understand
why they would get mad,
but then, you know, if you,
it's like a YouTube video.
If I make a YouTube video
and I'm a small YouTuber,
about this Mike Wazowski figure.
And then Garnt who has,
you know, a million,
let's say Garnt has 3 million.
And a YouTuber with 10,000 makes a video
about Mike Wazowski.
Garnt pretty much does like
nearly a one for one video,
you know, but in Garnt's style, right?
Yes, that guy will be angry.
He's like, "Garnt just made my video,
"but to a bigger audience.
"He's going to get all the views."
What you're not seeing is a huge kick
that you're going to get a
bunch of trickle-down views,
and that's what's gonna
happen with all the stuff.
Yeah, you're not gonna see
the immediate results of,
you know, getting the trickle down effect
from all these massive
events with like normies,
if you will.
- Right, but I think the problem is
that most of these "purists" don't see it
as a trickle down effect.
They just see it as like sloppy seconds.
- Yeah, well they see it as like
you're ruining the sanctity of my sport.
- It's like, "I wanted all
the guys to come to me first."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But you know, it's, you know, again,
more eyes, more sponsor money.
It's all good.
- Yeah, I mean, I think we
talked about this, like,
two weeks ago where you have
to evolve with the times.
And you have to find a way to
garner interest in your sport.
- Keep up or get left behind.
- Yeah, I mean, you
know, sports like boxing
and chess are lucky that
they've had such a good history
and a good legacy where that has, like,
kind of carried them a
bit in the modern age
where they have like a solid fan base.
But obviously, you know,
if they want to modernize
to a point where they want
to bring in a bunch of new
viewers, you got to mix it up.
And chess is having like
a massive Renaissance now.
It's huge.
- Yeah, I'm happy for chess.
- Like, chess streamers the biggest one's,
Hikaru's pulling in like
plus 25K I think a stream.
Like, and a bunch of the
other bigger ones pulling in,
like, over 5K viewers
on Twitch which is nuts.
- Like, you know, just
because you're, like,
pulling new viewers I feel
like that doesn't, like,
dilute the history that
has already been built.
Like, people are still gonna look back
to, like, the greats of the
time once they get into it.
- There's still the
greats going on right now.
It's just people don't like
that they're not the ones
that are solely being talked about.
- I mean, I think one of the
big things is that I think,
I don't know, I might
be talking out my ass.
But it seems like a lot of the
younger generations are less,
there's less of a focus on sports,
and more people are like
getting into, like, video games
and stuff like that.
Like, we literally talked
about how my nephew got bullied
because he wanted to play sports
but everyone was playing Fortnite.
Whereas when I was growing up-
- The other the way around.
- It was the other way around.
The cool kids were playing sport,
and that's why sports had
such, like, so many eyes on it.
And now I think because less
kids might be interested
in sports, you know,
you have to find a new way to
appeal to a younger audience.
Otherwise they're just
not gonna give a shit
at the end of the day.
- This is gonna sound weird.
But I think that video games are
now more accessible than sports.
- Yeah.
- I think that's why they're doing better.
Like, if you want to play a
game of rugby or football,
you need what?
Like, at least five a side.
You need a lot of people to get that done.
- And a lot of space.
- Yeah, a lot of space.
Like, anyone can play a video
game on their smartphone
or whatever, and anyone
can download chess.
- Anyone can play Madden.
- Yeah, like, it's like, you
know, a lot of the sports,
like I love swimming,
but like finding a swimming
pool in Japan is so hard.
- Yeah, without paying out the ass, right?
- Yeah, and there's not
one anywhere near us.
And like, I don't
fuckin' know where to go.
- I mean, there's like
gyms that have them,
but you have to pay, like, 150
bucks a month to access them.
- Yeah, most sports that I liked as a kid,
I realized how lucky I
was that there was like,
in the UK you have so many
sports centers all around
where you can do this,
but now I'm like, it's
so hard to do the sports
that I want to do and get into it.
- I want to get back into sports.
I don't know why.
- And get like a newer
generation into them.
'Cause it's like, I mean,
I'm not being funny.
How are you gonna convince
a kid to go play golf
when he can play Mario golf?
It's so accessible.
So easy.
- And the problem is golf looks so boring.
I'm sorry, but golf, like, I can not.
There are some sports where I'm just like,
I do not understand how
people can watch this
and be entertained because,
like, I've played golf before.
'Cause like I used to like live
kind of near a driving range
and it's just, so I had a period
where I just really enjoyed playing golf.
It was really satisfying
to like smack the ball.
Wasn't rich enough to afford
my own golf clubs, so (laughs)
- Another barrier to entry.
- Yeah, exactly.
That's my barrier to entry.
But it's really fun to play golf.
My God, it's so boring to watch!
- I can not watch a golf game.
- I mean, I'm sure the
people who are watching this
who love watching golf, and
I'm sorry to disappoint.
- But, like, there's so many
sports like that though.
Like, I used to play tennis like a lot.
But I can not sit down
and watch a tennis match.
- Oh, I don't know, I can.
- Some games are so good though.
But they are long.
They are long.
- They are very long.
- But I find it just so weird
and interesting how, like, I
myself love playing the sport
and yet I can't bear to sit
down and watch the sport.
Like, you'd think if
someone played the sport,
they would be just as
interested to watch it as well.
- No, not always.
Because the inverse is also true as well
where I might, like, have no
interest in playing the sport,
but I love watching it.
- Oh yeah.
That's more common I feel.
- Like, Garnt with League.
- Yeah, like me with League.
(everyone laughs)
- Is that a sport?
Ooh.
- Ooh!
But yeah, I mean, like
for example, I don't know.
There's always gonna be,
like, massive sports,
like football.
- Oh yeah.
- That's not gonna go away.
That's, like, too deeply ingrained.
But I feel like that's why the
Olympics are so weird to me.
Because you end up watching
a load of these sports
which you would in any other
circumstances have no interest
in watching, but it's the Olympics.
Does anyone want to watch
like men's volleyball?
Anyone?
- I never gave a shit about archery
until I watch it in the Olympics.
- There are a lot of
sports that are interesting
when you have them or you experience them
once every four years.
And your country's kind of in the race.
'Cause you gotta a horse
to root for, right?
You know, I don't think
archery week by week
Monday night archery, you know.
You know, you gotta build storylines.
You gotta build up characters.
- The Olympics definitely opened my eyes
to, like, some sports being really-
- Like, handball.
I never fuckin' saw handball before.
- Oh my God, curling.
I fucking love watching curling.
- Curling is fun to watch.
- I never thought I'd be into it.
But I was like, you know what?
This is hype as fuck.
I don't know why.
- Curling is like a Mario Party game
that actually turned into a real sport.
- It's like a mini game.
But, like, every round is curling.
- Literally, by accident.
They're like, "Let's just
fucking make it real."
- That's one sport I really want to play,
like try out.
Is there like a sport
that you've never done
that you want to try?
- Speed ice skating.
It looks so cool.
- That seems so dangerous.
- I thought of that 'cause there was
somebody who watches "Trash
Taste" reached out to me
on Twitter, and I was like,
'cause they were verified and
they had like 1,000 followers.
And I'm like, what the fuck?
And they were like-
- [Joey] Sports?
- Yeah, they were a pro
ice skater in like America?
Canada?
And they're like, "Yeah,
I love Trash Taste."
And they were on the Olympic team.
- Oh wow.
- For like ice skating.
And they watched us.
I think ice skating is real cool.
Real cool.
Teach me.
Nah, I love ice skating.
I'd love to like go fast and do it.
But that's too dangerous.
- Yeah, it's dangerous as fuck.
- I'd slam my face.
- I'd have to, like, get
past that mental barrier
of just like, you know when
you reach a certain speed
and especially if you're not used to it
you have to get past that
barrier of just like,
"I'm going a bit too fast now.
"If I fall, it's really gonna hurt."
- You know what Olympic
sport I want to exist
but will never exist is like,
you know when you go
to like Round One here
and you get the Zorb ball around you?
- Oh yeah!
- It's like football where
you're wearing, like,
the balls where you can
just run into each other.
That'd be such a fun Olympic sport.
- Imagine just like 18 people on the field
just fucking crashing into each other.
- Honestly if you ever come
to Japan, come to Round One
'cause most Round One have this.
You're gonna see it on screen.
- It's spo-cha, right?
- It's spo-cha yeah.
- So you're gonna see it on screen now.
You can easily get access to this.
- [Joey] Yeah, they're everywhere.
- [Garnt] And then a lot
of Round Ones in Japan.
- [Connor] They had like BB gun shooting.
- [Garnt] Yeah, it's surprisingly.
I remember when we did it
right in the fuckin' summer,
which was a fuckin' stupid move.
- Right after we had like
the biggest bowl of curry.
We were like, we were
in the fuckin' Zorb ball
just like rolling around.
We're just like, "Oh, I'm gonna throw up."
(everyone laughs)
- It's surprisingly, it was surprisingly-
- We should go back there.
We haven't been there in so long.
- It was surprisingly fucking
tiring to do that though.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- It looks really light
to just run around.
No, it's not.
It is kinda like playing
a Mario Party game.
'Cause like, it feels like,
'cause you're playing football
but it's got this like
really janky physics engine.
(everyone laughs)
It's like trying to drive
a car in like Cyberpunk.
- Custom game mode.
- Like, big head mode where
you're just fuckin' top heavy.
- It's literally Gang Beast controls.
(everyone laughs)
- Yeah, fun as fuck.
- I'd love that to be a sport.
- Are you guys gonna go watch
any of the Olympic sports
if it happens this year?
- How the fuck do I apply?
- Supposedly now that like,
I think it's been confirmed
that they're not gonna
bring any foreigners in.
So, but, you can go see it at the stadium
which means there's gonna
be way more available seats
for the actual Olympics.
I kind of want to do it just because like-
- Do you know how to get tickets?
- I'm gonna look into it.
- I have no idea.
- Because, like, if I can find it out,
then I'd want to go just to say I've been.
- Yeah, the only time I've
ever seen tickets available,
the only way you could win
it was by buying something
from Panasonic and you get
entered into a lottery.
Which of maybe you'll
get the right to buy it.
- Yeah, that sounds like a very Japanese-
- That sounds like a Japanese thing to do.
- I don't wanna buy Panasonic.
I want a ticket to the Olympics.
- Because this would be the second time
that I've lived in a city
where the Olympics was held
'cause I was there for London.
- I wasn't there in London.
- You weren't there in London?
- I was in Wales at that time.
- So, yeah, I was living
in London at the time.
And yeah, I mean, I...
During the normal Olympics
things just, like,
get super, super busy,
and I don't really like
crowds that much anyway.
So, like, I didn't want to go
through the hassle of going
to a sporting event.
And I don't know.
I didn't care enough about
the sport for me to want to go
to this big sporting event where I,
you know, I literally just said,
the Olympics is where you watch sports
you normally don't care about,
but you watch it 'cause it's the Olympics.
So, I don't even know what
sports I would want to watch.
- I don't know, I feel like-
- Would you just want to watch any sport?
- But also, what if you watch a sport,
but it's like a bad game,
like it's a bad matchup.
It's like a stomp.
It'd be like America versus
like Venezuela in basketball.
Like, it's like, oh, come on.
- Obviously Venezuela's gonna crush.
- Obviously, obviously.
- No, I feel like, I don't know.
With those kinds of stuff,
I feel it's just you go to
just enjoy the atmosphere,
you know?
'Cause like I remember-
- How many have you been?
- I've never been to the Olympics, but-
- So, how would you know
the atmosphere's good?
- Because, well, I mean every
other sporting event I've been
to has been, 'cause, like,
I remember I went to go watch, like-
- But like Japanese
atmosphere though in a crowd,
they're not very rowdy, are they?
- Yeah.
- That's not true.
I went to go see the baseball here,
and it was really, really fun.
I mean, it was a shit game.
- Really?
What was fun about it?
I say this having been to
a baseball game in the US
and I kind of found it a bit boring.
- Oh, really?
- You don't love the kiss cam, Garnt?
What?
- I feel, okay, okay,
this might be a bit biased
'cause I actually quite
enjoy watching the baseball
every now and then.
- I also don't enjoy cricket either.
I'm just making an enemy of, like, the US,
(Joey laughs)
Australia, India now.
Who else?
- All the sports.
They all suck.
No, well, 'cause, like,
I remember I went to go watch a rugby game
and it's like I'm not
huge into the rugby, but-
- Watching rugby games is fun though.
- Yeah, on the TV.
- Oh, and in person.
- Oh yeah.
I went to go watch the
rugby, and it's like,
it was a shit game 'cause our
team got fuckin' destroyed,
but I still had a really fun time
just because of the atmosphere.
- Yeah, everyone's rowdy.
- Yeah, but baseball was
the same thing as well.
Like, my team was losing, but
I didn't really give a fuck,
'cause it was just, I don't
know, it was just fun.
- Yeah, 'cause like how we
had fun was just getting
very, very drunk.
It was in Milwaukee-
- That's typically what you do.
- And like everyone was just very drunk,
and it was just like,
"I don't know what the fuck's going on.
"I'm having a good time now
though 'cause I'm pretty drunk."
- "Yes, please, another Miller Lite."
- "Yes, I'll pay for another
eight dollar hot dog."
- "Oh, yes, this hot dog that
is not meat, I'll have that."
- I don't know,
I just like having an active
component to my sport, I guess.
(Joey laughs)
How can I say this?
I don't like when sports are stop starts.
You know?
I like it to be, like-
- So you're not into like the NFL?
- Oh my God, bro, watching NFL is hard.
The amount of ads they have.
- But, it's also very
stop start heavy game.
- But like, I feel like the NFL is like,
I can get into the NFL
because when the game is in motion,
like, it's hard to find a
sport as exciting as the NFL
when everything is in motion.
- Garnt's winning over
our American audience.
(everyone laughs)
- There's so many things going on
in such a short period of time.
Whereas, you know, I look
at something like cricket
or baseball and there's
only, you know, there's-
- Yeah, it's very stop start heavy.
- It's very stop, start, and
there's, you know, there's,
I'm gonna sound like,
sound so bad.
It's just, I just see like
a guy trying to hit a ball.
(everyone laughs)
- What do you prefer
American football or rugby?
- Ooh, it's hard.
I think rugby.
Overall I prefer rugby.
But I've had more exciting, like,
moments watching American football.
- I feel then you would really enjoy AFL.
- What's AFL?
- The Australian football.
It's like,
it's basically like NFL except-
- I didn't know Australia had-
- If we're representing our own country,
I have to talk about AFL
'cause someone's gonna talk about it.
But AFL is basically like it's,
it's Australian football,
but think of NFL,
but if it was just one continuous
play that never stopped.
- Right.
Okay, that sounds pretty fun.
- And it's like twice
the field size as well.
- Sounds exhausting.
- It is fucking,
AFL players are legitimate athletes.
Like they-
- How do they do that in Australian heat?
- As opposed to like every other sport.
- I think I saw something which is like
in an average AFL game,
a player can run upwards
of like 20 kilometers.
And it's a two hour game.
- Fuck.
- Oh my God.
- But they split it.
- I bet they made that game
that long on how long
Australians need to drink.
Probably
- Pretty much.
- "Another round."
- That's why AFL games are
the best to watch at home.
It's just like two hours of drinking.
Fuck yeah, dude!
- 30 minute recess, you know?
It's perfect.
- No, but I think you'd really like it.
If you don't like the
start stop aspect of NFL,
I think you'd really like AFL.
- 'Cause I do like a lot of sports
where like there's a lot of
things in motion, you know.
Love football, love watching basketball.
- When I went to Canada, I
loved watching the hockey.
- Hockey's great.
- I think I could really get into hockey.
- Hockey was fuckin' fun.
- Hockey's really fun to watch.
- So fast paced.
- That's a sport where I think watching
that, like, live would
be super, super fun.
- I'd love to watch that.
- Like, the atmosphere
just looks super, like-
- And in the back of your head, it's like,
"Ooh, this might turn into a fight."
(everyone laughs)
- Exactly, right?
- Sadly I've never lived anywhere
where it's, like, a popular sport
which is so sad 'cause I want to.
But every time when I went to Canada,
it was, like, literally like I
was watching it all the time.
So fun.
I want to go and watch one
next time I go to Canada
or America.
But yeah, see, I said something
nice about America for once.
(everyone laughs)
I got an angry email that was like,
they were like,
the subject was "please
educate yourself on America."
Something like, "You talk
about America all the time,
"but you always get everything
wrong in our culture.
"Totally incorrect."
I should find it.
I think I deleted it though
'cause I was like, shut the fuck up.
(everyone laughs)
- What about, like, Sumo?
- Sumo?
Ooh.
- 'Cause I really want to go watch Sumo.
- I think that would be fun to watch.
I don't watch enough
Sumo to have an opinion
or haven't tried to watch enough Sumo
to have an opinion about it.
- Someone in my Twitch chat notified me
that there's a Twitch channel
that streams the Sumo.
- Really?
- Yeah, with English commentary.
- Oh my God.
- So like every now and then when it's on,
I just kind of flick it on,
and leave it in the background
while I'm working 'cause I'm just like,
like, don't even have to turn my TV on.
It's on Twitch.
It's fucking great.
- Have you ever, like, gotten
into a sport or something
because of a show you watched or an anime
or something like that?
'Cause, like, the only reason
I gave the NFL a chance was
'cause of fuckin' "Eyeshield."
I sound like such a weeb for saying this,
but I'm just like, okay, I'm
gonna give the NFL a chance.
- Mine's even worse.
I got into tennis 'cause
of "Prince of Tennis."
(everyone laughs)
Deadass.
- I got into like cycling
from "Yowamushi Pedal."
- Did you actually?
- Yeah, it's fuckin' hype.
Okay, I found the email.
"Hey Connor, love the podcast.
"But if you could do me
"and the rest of American fans a favor,
"could you please stop
throwing misconceptions around
"about us?
"Maybe educate yourself a little bit
"on how we do things here
"instead of believing
the typical stereotypes.
"It's almost every podcast
now you say something
"about America that's completely false
"and only applies to 1% of
us and is just annoying."
- Like, what?
- I don't know.
I wish they gave examples,
so I could be like,
"Okay, that's fair."
Are we wrong about things
most of the time, Meilyne?
A lot of it?
(everyone laughs)
A lot if it's right?
- A lot of it's right apparently.
- Here's the problem with America, right.
(everyone laughs)
Wait, wait.
- Go on.
- Okay, okay.
- Well, there's many problems.
So, so.
Something that applies to
one state does not apply
to another state.
'Cause America is fuckin' huge.
- It's so varied, right?
- Like, Meilyne, do you not think of like,
you feel very different
to other states, right?
Like, you don't feel like
you have anything in common
with people from like Florida, right?
Yeah, so like someone from,
like, I can relate to someone
from any part of the UK.
I can understand everything.
I understand how you live.
Like, everything's the same.
But for like someone in like California,
you can't possibly relate completely
to someone from like Minnesota.
- No, no.
Totally different culture.
Totally different vibe.
- Shut up, Meilyne.
Like, there's so many,
'cause it's so vast.
There's so many different,
like, micro-cultures
and everything.
- Yeah, like, definitely like
whenever I go visit
Sidney's family in Milwaukee
and Wisconsin, it's like,
there's definitely a
Midwestern culture that's-
- Oh yeah.
From traveling the US you realize
how different they all view
each other as Americans.
- [Joey] Yeah, it's completely different.
- It's really interesting.
So fuck you.
(everyone laughs)
I'm kidding, I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
He did say he was a big
fan of the podcast though.
Sorry.
- Have you guys seen
any, like, obscure sport
that you, like, that you only know about
because it's been recommended
on YouTube or something
but then like, it actually
looks pretty fuckin' hype?
- What was it?
Oh, there was one.
I forgot what it was,
but I think it's, like,
an Indian sport or a Southeast Asian sport
where it's volleyball,
but you kick the ball.
What the fuck is it called?
- Wait, what?
- I've seen this.
- Sepaktakraw.
Sepaktakraw.
It's literally just think of volleyball,
but like, you know how with volleyball
you pass it with your hands.
But instead of your hands, you kick it.
- [Garnt] Isn't that just football tennis?
- [Joey] Kinda.
(Garnt laughs)
- Don't say that, Garnt.
- Every sepaktakraw player's like,
"How dare you?
"How dare you ruin the
sanctity of our sport?"
- Well, that sounds cool.
Like, have you seen stuff
like professional tag
and stuff like that?
- Professional tag is fuckin' awesome.
Like, Vox did a video about
how it came to be as well.
- How did it come to be?
- Just a guy who was like really obsessed
with the idea of making like tag courses.
Just kept, like, building them,
and people were like, "Yo,
this is pretty fun actually."
- You know what's one obscure
sport I really enjoy watching?
Ultimate frisbee.
That's a really fuckin'-
- [Garnt] That's really fun.
- In the US I think it's quite popular?
'Cause like Marques Brownlee plays it.
- [Joey] Oh really?
- Yeah, he plays it.
- Is it an Olympic sport?
It's not, is it?
- No, no.
- It's not an Olympic sport.
- He mentioned it quite a
lot though in his videos.
And he's shared videos of him playing it.
Pretty cool.
- I guess outside of America,
it's not really like a thing.
I mean, I remember we
played it for, like, sports
once for school, and it was really fun.
- Yeah, I mean, we played
it in school as well,
so it was definitely a thing,
but it was more seen of just-
- It sounds like the
most college sport ever.
(everyone laughs)
You know what I mean?
- Ivy League past time.
- "I have the luxury of being able
"to play ultimate frisbee."
- "Ultimate frisbee."
- "Yes."
It's the ultimate,
it's the ultimate that like...
- Yeah, why ultimate?
- We don't have ultimate football.
We do.
- What if they called
it like epic frisbee?
- I'd be playing it right now.
- "Would you like to join
our epic frisbee team?"
- That's the kind of sport
you'd think you'd see on Twitch
or something.
(everyone laughs)
- Epic frisbee.
- I don't know, I could see
ultimate frisbee on Twitch.
Why not?
That'd be fuckin' awesome.
- Like, POV.
- POV.
You're a frisbee.
- POV you're an ultimate frisbee.
- I mean, I feel like Twitch
would be the perfect platform
for a lot of these more obscure sports,
like professional arm wrestling as well.
Have you seen that?
That's like the most dude
bro sport I've ever seen.
- It's like the slapping.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Moist Critikal loved to commentate on.
- Like, what I love
about watching professional
arm wrestling is
that, like, they're egging
each other on to do better.
It's almost like a gym session
where it's like, "You got this, bro!
"You got this, bro!"
- Actually, you know what the best one is?
I decided this is the best one.
The best sport you've seen
on the internet three times,
forget about, but remember is badass.
It's the like Sumo, but
with the, like, robot wars.
- Oh yeah.
- What?
- It's a Sumo ring with like,
where they have like mini robots,
and they have to push each other out.
And it's from where the
omae wa mou shindeiru,
like that really popular
edit where it like.
It's such a good video.
Play a gif.
- [Man] omae wa mou shindeiru.
(man yells)
- Yeah, it's like the,
what was that show?
- "Robot Wars."
- No, but America did a version of it.
"BattleBots" that's it.
- I think that clip is from a Japanese-
- From the Japanese one.
- Where they do it with miniature ones.
'Cause the "BattleBots" and
"Robot Wars" in the UK were
like fuckin' giant robots.
- These ones are like tabletop.
- Yeah, it's not meant to destroy.
It's supposed to push the other thing out.
And it's pretty cool.
Really fuckin' cool.
- There's nothing getting
destroyed, I am not interested.
- My man monkey brain not
happy, no destruction.
- I mean, I kinda miss "Robot Wars."
I don't know when it got canceled.
Is it still a thing?
It's probably not still a thing.
- I don't think it's
still a thing anymore.
I don't think "BattleBots"
is still a thing either.
Meilyne, check that out.
- Yeah, it's one of the few
things we had growing up
that made engineering look cool.
'Cause it's really hard to
make engineering look cool.
But you see these like mechanics-
- That would be like a really cool way
to teach engineering, coding,
like all in one thing.
Get them to make just a
little thing fuckin' move
around a little bit.
Like, why not teach that?
- The one thing I loved
about "BattleBots" though was
just like, just the fluctuation
between like the different people
who clearly had completely
different skills in engineering.
Like, one robot was, like,
this robot has an automated
arm that can, you know,
grab and pick up robots.
And then there's another dude,
like the challenger comes in.
It's like, "I attached
60 knives onto this.
"And the only function
it can do is go forwards
"and backwards."
- It's a chainsaw on wheels.
Literally it.
- It's so funny.
- And you see it like
some like piddly robots
that had like the most
depressing flipper of all time.
Like, couldn't even flip my grandma,
and then it goes up against
like fuckin' Hypno-Disc
or something and just
gets absolutely destroyed.
- Half of them, like, don't
even move in practice.
So, it's just a doorstopper on wheels.
- And then like, I don't know
if "BattleBots" had this,
but the UK one had this where, like,
the showrunners had their
own, like, OPS robots
that would just like when
the nothing was happening,
they'd be like, "Send out
Charles" or something.
- "Send out Sir Killalot."
- And then like this just fucking massive,
clearly like absolutely god
tier engineering robot came out.
- Like, created by NASA.
(everyone laughs)
- Just started like gorilla
smashing them around,
and it's like, oh, that's
kind of anticlimactic.
- [Meilyne] Apparently
"BattleBots" was supposed
to come back in 2020, but it's postponed.
- Oh, wow.
- Oh, okay.
"BattleBots" is coming back.
- When did "BattleBots" end?
So wow, two thousands it
ends, it's coming back soon.
- I'm just getting reminded of all, like,
these old television shows I
used to watch as a kid now.
Do you remember "Gladiators?"
Was that a part of-
- That's very, very old.
- That's very,
that's like 90s.
- That sounds really familiar.
What is that?
- It's basically like-
- Very much inspired,
like, the whole, like,
kind of sporty-esque, like,
really intense physical sports.
- It was kind of like, instead of like,
instead of like,
what are like the shows
that like Fall Guys
and stuff is based around?
- "Wipeout."
- So instead of, like, going
against an obstacle course,
you'd have an obstacle course,
but then you'd be competing
against a gladiator
which was like this kind of, like,
really fit muscular person.
And there would be this
competitive element
where you'd have to beat, like,
beat this person on this obstacle course,
something like that.
- Or you'd have to just,
like, literally fight them.
(everyone laughs)
- That's the final hurdle.
- Basically.
- You get to the end,
he's just standing there.
- I mean, the best way I can describe it,
it's basically something very,
it's like "Wipeout"
with wrestling basically.
- So it's, like, real time,
like, you're fighting,
well, not fighting but like-
- So, there's like one,
I think there's one
event in it where, like,
you both have, like, the long poles
with like the cushions on the end,
and you fuckin' have to
smack each other off.
- Oh yes, yes, I remember that.
- Basically giant cotton buds.
Try to push each other off the platform.
- Yeah, I remember that.
- I know that show is old
'cause I think when I was
watching that like very
early 2000s everyone was
wearing like latex and spandex.
And I'm like, oh yeah-
- I'm pretty sure all that's just taken
from "Takeshi's Castle," right?
- Yeah, what was the other one?
The Japanese one was called, like,
I think it was, it's called, like,
"Ultimate Banzuke" or something.
- Oh yeah.
- You heard of this one?
- Yeah, I think so.
- Where like, literally they will do,
this show is so fun.
You should watch clips on YouTube.
It's really fuckin' cool.
So, what they would do is
that they would have like someone,
either they would be a generic thing
or they'd have an expert.
So, they bring on like
10 expert pogo people,
and they would build, like,
a fuckin' impossible pogo obstacle course.
And they would have to do it.
And, like, the shit
they would do is insane.
It wasn't just general people.
It was like, no, they get professionals.
And there'll be people who
like, they'd have to be,
they bring people who are
professionals at like handstands,
and they'd have to do a whole course
handstand walking around.
Like, going upstairs, going on wobbly-
- Yeah, I've definitely seen that.
- It's really fucking cool.
You should watch this.
Just type it in.
I think it's, I'll have to-
- "Ultimate Banzuke," right?
Something like that.
Yeah.
- And, like, the stuff
they had to do was crazy.
Like, they had that, you know,
that Mario Party game
where you have to, like,
there's like seven things stacked
and you have a hammer and hit it.
- [Joey] Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- They had a game where
two people had to do that,
and they had to like, hit them all out.
But obviously when you hit it,
it would like tip the thing over.
It was really cool.
- That's based off like a
traditional Japanese, like, toy.
- Yeah, yeah.
It was pretty cool.
- What's like the best concept of, like,
a reality TV program that you've seen?
- Like, physical game show challenge?
- Anything.
- I like "Ninja Warrior."
The original, the Japanese original.
- "Sasuke."
- Yeah, that was really good.
- There was this really
old reality TV show
that Channel Four made.
I can't remember the name
'cause it was, like, a one-off series.
But I always remember it
because I thought the concept was genius.
Because what they did is this was,
this was way back when
when "Big Brother" was,
like, a massive thing,
but the twist was, they
took these group of people
that weren't exactly the
brightest bunch of people,
but, you know, wanted to
be on a reality TV show.
And they would basically,
they basically convinced them
that they were going to go to space.
- Oh, I think I remember this.
- So what happens is they literally go,
they literally, like, take
them astronaut training.
And make them go through all the training,
but also feed them like a
bit of fake information.
Because they had this real mock spaceship,
and they taught them that, you know,
we are using new technology
where it doesn't require rockets.
It's kind of like an
airplane where it, like,
slowly circles up to
the Earth's atmosphere.
(everyone laughs)
And these guys would believe it.
They thought they were, like,
being trained in Russia.
- What was the name of the show?
- I can't remember.
I'm gonna have to look it up
because it was a genius show.
And, like, at any point, if like,
at any point one of them
could have found out.
'Cause they were,
the producer said, you know,
you're gonna be trained in Russia.
It's not gonna be in England.
And what happened is they
just took them on a plane
and just, like, circled round
and just landed in like an
abandoned airfield in Surrey
or something like that.
So, they were just, like,
in the middle of England
thinking they were going to space.
And they actually took
some of these people,
and just, have you ever been on like one
of those fake rollercoaster rides?
Where it's like, it's kinda like-
- Like, the 4D ones?
- Yeah, like the 4D ones
where, you know, you just kind
of, like, have this spaceship
that just kind of tilts up.
- It's called "Space Cadets."
Aired in 2005 on Channel Four.
Channel Four normally does
all the really bizarre,
really unique game shows in the UK.
- If you got, like, if you
got some time you want to kill
that's honestly, it was
such a good concept.
And it was a one off as
well, one off season.
It was just-
- It sounds hilarious.
- It was fuckin' hilarious.
Highly recommend it.
- Yeah, the first thing that comes up
when you Google it is like controversies.
It must be quite controversial.
- I guess so.
- I want to watch that now.
That sounds awesome.
- Yeah, that sounds really funny.
- The UK has some pretty unique game shows
like the hunted one.
- Yeah, the hunted one.
- The hunted one was cool.
Basically there's a game show in the UK,
I think it was literally called "Hunted."
And they would have, like, I
think six pairs or 10 pairs,
something around that,
and basically what they
would do is they were like,
all right, you have like one day,
and then we're gonna
start trying to, like,
track you as if you're a fugitive.
So, like any of your,
if you use your phone, if you do anything,
you make calls, you go to
places, like they'll find you.
And so some people were really good at it
and some people are terrible at it.
And like, yeah.
And then they had to survive two weeks?
- Yeah, two weeks.
- Two weeks, and then go
to a location to get, like,
a plane to, like, to escape.
- [Joey] Right, right, right.
- Yeah, well, one team did win.
- That sounds really fun.
- It was really cool.
It was really popular the first season,
and the second season I
think was a bit shitter
and didn't do too well.
- I feel that's a concept, like,
at first that would be
like, wow, that's cool.
But then I feel it'd get old quite fast.
- Yeah, because there's
only so much you can do
once you know the formula and
once you know the secrets.
- There's something like,
the logistics behind that
must've been like crazy.
Like, I wonder how much of
that was faked though as well
because you surely can't
have access to all the, like,
the police force's like ability, right?
'Cause it's just a waste of
police time and services.
- That's just a lot of government money.
- "Hold on, wait, we've
gotta find the fake one."
I wonder.
But like in a concept, really cool.
- Yeah.
Was that on Channel Four as well?
- That was on Channel Four as well.
- Channel Four made some
good, like, one-off reality-
- I'm surprised I never
heard of any of these.
- Yeah, Channel Four makes
really good TV shows in general.
- Yeah, like, some of my
favorite are definitely, like,
some of the Derren Brown specials.
I don't know how famous Derren
Brown is outside of the UK.
- Right now probably not so much.
- Never heard of him.
- You've never heard of Derren Brown?
Oh my God.
Some of the shit this man did was crazy.
His favorite thing that he's ever done.
So Derren Brown is a magician from the UK.
- He's a magician that basically like-
- Hypnotist as well?
- Sorry?
- Like, a hypnotist as well?
- I can't remember exactly
what he calls himself,
but he's more like a
mental magician where-
- Mentalist?
- Not even like-
- It's fucking-
- Something about the word
mentalist makes it sound fake.
- This man is just one of a kind.
- Yeah, like, he's a showman.
He says, like, "Everything I do is,"
like, it's not so much that it's fake,
but like it's, there
is like magic involved.
He doesn't claim to have special powers
or something like that.
He just claims to understand
psychology and plays on that.
- Yeah, so there's this
one TV show that he did
and it is literally my favorite,
and it's so big brain, this whole thing.
So I'll spoil the end of it.
So I'll warn you I'm gonna do that,
but I'll spoil it for you,
but it's still cool either
way, if you watch it.
So, what happens is this TV show starts
and you're following this
perspective of this one woman.
- I know it.
- This one's so good.
And so basically what happens is is that,
so the show is that he,
basically he knows
which horse is gonna win
in these horse races.
- So, the exact name of the
special is called "The System."
So, the way he markets it
is that he has a system
that can 100% predict
which horse is going to win
in a horse race.
- And so it's like this middle-aged woman
and you know, we follow her.
He calls her up, he's like,
"Listen, bet on this horse, go now."
So she goes and she bets on it,
and the cameras are following her.
She bets on it.
She wins.
It's like, oh, shit, okay.
And then he rings her up again.
He's like,
"Right now, put all of your
money on this horse now."
Like, a week later.
And she puts all the money on it.
She wins again.
It's like, what the fuck?
How is he doing this?
This is legit, like,
this is a fully legitimate,
it's, like, a public gambling
that anyone can bet on.
- It's a real horse race.
- He gives them the money.
He gives them a thousand pounds, right?
I think.
- I can't remember.
It's been a while, but,
no, I don't think he gives them any money.
- So anyway, she wins
and it happens again.
And he's like, "All right, now, bet again.
"All the money on this horse."
She does it again, and she wins.
And I think it's one more time.
He's like, "All right,
now this is the final one.
"Bet all of your money on this again."
And she wins.
And you're like, what
the fuck is going on?
Like, he's literally guessing.
And then he reveals,
and as the episode ends
that like he's literally done
like a tournament bracket
of like, every single
race there's nine horses.
So, every single race he's
literally found nine people
and told them to bet on
the different horses.
He's literally gone through
and done like a giant,
like, hundreds of races.
- It's like a pyramid.
So, like at the beginning he started
with like thousands of
thousands of contestants.
And he said, you know, I, you know,
he didn't reveal who his identity was.
He was just like an anonymous tip.
And so, you know, part of, like,
certain amount of people
won, they got eliminated.
He gave them a refund,
and then he went up to the next bracket.
And then he kept, he basically
kept enough of a group
of people to make sure there
was at least one person.
- And it's so simple.
- That's so cool.
- But when you're following the story
and her perspective, it
seems like literal magic.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Because the message he
was trying to say was like,
don't forget about perspective.
Just because you are winning
doesn't mean that, like,
doesn't mean like there's a magical system
or something like that.
It's all to do with probability.
- That sounds right up my alley.
- Dude, he's literally a fuckin' genius.
His shows are amazing.
And like, he did one where,
he's done so many crazy shows.
- I think one of my
favorite ones is, like,
the ones where he actually
faked a zombie apocalypse.
- Oh, that sounds familiar.
I might've seen that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So basically he takes this one guy.
So how he gets people in his specials is
that people apply to be on his specials.
- Right.
- But he doesn't tell anyone
that they've succeeded.
- What it is.
- He doesn't tell anyone
that they've succeeded.
- Right.
- So he gets thousands and
thousands of applicants,
and he chooses one out of everyone.
So, he takes this guy and he puts,
he basically hypnotized
him, so he like passes out,
and he wakes up in this
like abandoned hospital.
- Right, right.
- And you know, it's basically
just this guy going through
a zombie apocalypse.
- Like, the "Truman Show."
'Cause they get everyone around him to act
and go along as if there's
a zombie apocalypse.
So this guy literally believes
that there's like a zombie apocalypse.
- I think this is on Netflix as well.
So, you can actually
watch this on Netflix.
- There's another one where he sees
if he can convince
someone to commit murder.
- Jesus.
- Like, fake murder.
He sets up the situation.
That one's not as good as the other ones,
but like, they all vary in quality,
but you're definitely
gonna have an experience.
You definitely can't
find anything like it.
- What's the name of the show again?
- Just type in Darren Brown.
- Derren, Derren.
- Derren Brown?
- D-E-R-R-E-N.
But he's done a lot of stuff.
- His live shows are
really popular as well.
- I've been to his live shows actually.
- Oh really?
- It's really good.
- Does like a lot of psychology things.
He basically like
manipulates like perception.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's really just interesting stuff.
- Yeah, it gives you a lot of perspective,
and he, you know, he goes in saying,
you know, all of this is just magic.
You know?
Like he, a lot of-
- None of this is magic.
- Sorry?
- You said all of this is magic.
- No, no.
- "So I'm just a fuckin' magician.
"You guys know me.
"Hogwarts diploma right here."
(everyone laughs)
- No, 'cause like watching his stuff,
he doesn't pretend to be,
he doesn't pretend like he has powers
or something like that.
It's all showmanship-
- That's how British people like it.
- But that's my favorite type of musician,
magician.
Like, fuckin',
what's the...
- David Blaine?
- No, not David Blaine.
Penn and Teller.
That's what I like about Penn and Teller
'cause they're just like,
"We're not fuckin' magicians.
"We're just good at what we do."
It's all just slight
of hand shit, you know.
Unlike, you know, like fuckin' Chris Angel
who's like, "Yes, I am the
second coming of Christ."
- "I'm literally fucking dying."
(everyone laughs)
"I literally die."
- To be fair, every now
and then I love going back
and watching like Chris
Angel clips on YouTube
just because, like, I
remember back in the day
when I watched, like,
Chris Angel being like,
"Yeah, I split this woman in half."
And I was just like,
oh my God, this man is,
he's actually a magician.
- This man is insane.
- He's like, "Yes, I'm walking on water."
And it's totally not just, like,
see-through fuckin'
plastic boards on the pool.
- Were you around when David Blaine did
that stunt in London where he would like-
- Stayed in the cage?
- Yeah, stayed in the cage
or something for like,
how long did he stay in there for?
- A month wasn't it?
- Yeah, it was a long time.
- It was like a month without
any food or something.
I remember just thinking,
there were so many
moments during that month
where he just got fucking
shit on by all, like,
the fuckin' chavs.
(everyone laughs)
It was so bad.
'Cause like it was back in
the time when, you know,
England had this nice
prim and proper image
to Americans, especially.
And you just had, like,
these fuckin' people, like,
these Londoners who were just
chucking paint balls at him
and shit like this.
I felt so bad.
- Chavs in London are
a different breed, man.
Man, it, just like as well,
like when I saw that he's like
staying in there for 30 days,
I'm like, why?
Why?
Is the record really worth it?
Like, I get it, like, the stunt.
But like, is this fun?
- I mean, I guess the fact that
we're still talking about it
to this day is worth it, right?
- Yeah, true.
I guess that's the point, right?
Like, I just lose a month of my life
to get a bit of clout.
- To be talked about.
- He's the ultimate clout chaser.
(everyone laughs)
I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
This shit's very impressive.
He could probably kill me
with magic for all I know.
Make a frog come out of my ass.
(everyone laughs)
- Shitting out frogs.
- Have you seen his Ted Talk?
- No.
- He had a Ted Talk,
like breaking down how
he did one of his stunts,
which was like how he stayed under water
and like broke the world record.
- Yeah, that was cool.
- And, like, he was going
through the process of, like,
they tried a load of different things.
Like, they tried stuffing, like,
a airbag into his stomach to
give him like a breathing tube.
And that just-
- Isn't that just cheating?
- No, it's magic.
- That just ended up horribly.
Then they just kind of, like,
tried a lot of different ways
to see if this was possible.
And then, like, the conclusion
they came to was just,
let's just fuckin' do it properly.
So yeah, he-
- Let's just, you know, train.
- Yeah, let's just almost drown myself,
and that's basically what he did.
And it's just like, man,
this man has just monetized
being fuckin' mental, right?
- He's a true mentalist.
(everyone laughs)
- Like, it's respectable that he did that,
and he achieved that, like,
all the credit to him,
but my God, you must-
- It's the magic of willpower.
That's all it is.
- It's the fucking craziest
people that do, like,
the fuckin' like,
most absurd shit.
- Dumbest shit.
- That, like, you know,
you have to be a little
bit crazy to be a genius,
I think, you know what I mean?
Like, I think there
has to be a little bit.
- Yeah, I mean, what was that quote again?
It's like a genius is
just an insane person
with an audience.
- Is it really?
(everyone laughs)
- I don't know who said that
quote, but it's a quote.
- I just, my God, yeah.
I don't know.
It's like going back to the caving stuff,
we spoke about a few weeks ago, right?
It's like, it has to,
there's gotta be some dopamine
deficiency going on here
that requires you to like, need to like,
I'm like, I have a good meal and I'm like,
damn, that dopamine hit was good.
Someone has like a seven 11,
like, no, I gotta fuckin'
climb the building instead.
I gotta climb the seven 11 to get a hit.
(everyone laughs)
You're like, what?
What's going on?
- "Fear Factor?"
- What's "Fear Factor?"
- Oh, "Fear Factor."
Yeah, I mean-
- Didn't that have a lot of
controversy, "Fear Factor?"
- I mean, I've seen-
- Like, Joe Rogan did it, right?
'Cause it's either like,
you can eat your own shit
or drink your own piss.
- It's not even that bad though.
It's like, I remember, like,
I think I saw one episode or one season
where, like, the final gross
or whatever the fuck it was called,
it was like the worst
meal was, it was balut.
You know the-
- It was what?
- It was balut which
is, like, the duck fetus
that they eat in, like, the Philippines.
And it's like, I remember
'cause when I went to the
Philippines for the first time,
Aki was like, "Do you wanna try balut?"
I'm like, "What the fuck is that?"
He's like, "It's a duck fetus."
It was the worst thing
they had on "Fear Factor."
And I ate it and I'm like,
people on "Fear Factor"
are fuckin' pussies.
(everyone laughs)
- Get Joey on "Fear Factor."
- There's something weird
about the fact of being like-
- I'm like, this is delicious.
What are you on about?
- I can just imagine someone
went to the Philippines,
and then someone really politely is like,
"This is our culture.
"This is what we eat."
And he's like, "I can't wait
to put this on Fear Factor!
"People are gonna eat this!"
Like, it's so weird about that.
- Like, I understand like, you know,
eating cockroach or something
right where it's like-
- Something that shouldn't be eaten.
- Something that shouldn't be eaten-
- And isn't really widely
eaten by any culture,
I kind of like, I get it.
Like, you know-
- And then there's taking,
like, an obscure food
from like a cultural background.
And it's like, "This is
disgusting, isn't it?"
(everyone laughs)
- "Look how vile this is!
"Someone's gonna eat this shit!"
- "Someone's gonna eat this shit!"
Meanwhile everyone in the
Philippines is like...
- The Philippine audience
is like Mike Wazowski.
What?
- It's either McDonald's or this.
- Are they really gonna
waste that balut like that?
- Oh my God.
- I don't know, man.
I'm Thai, and Thai people eat water bugs,
and I don't stand by that shit.
I still haven't forgotten, Meilyne.
I still have not forgotten.
- You're not gonna like go and be like,
"Mom, can I take some water bugs back?
"I'm filming Fear Factor.
"This is crazy!"
- "Nobody eats this!"
- "Sarah has a choice
between jumping off a bridge
"or eating a bug.
"She chose to jump off a bridge."
- What is "Fear Factor?"
I've never watched it.
- Isn't it you get two choices?
No, am I crazy?
- Was it two choices?
No, I think-
- I don't fuckin' give
a shit, it's garbage.
- It's just a show where it's, like,
contestants basically
line up and being like,
if you eat this, then you
go onto the next round.
And if you survive the entire round,
you get a prize money
or something like that.
But like the food or what
you have to do is, like,
usually considered gross
according to Americans at least
and like-
- Vegetables.
I'm gonna get shit after.
(everyone laughs)
- The first step-
- Okay, okay, now the email is warranted.
I'll give you that.
Okay, fair enough.
- You know what meme with that kid
who's just got vein popping out?
It's like,
Connor when he hasn't shit
on America for 30 minutes.
(everyone laughs)
- True, true, true.
Hey, I think it's fair fuckin' game.
You don't see me fuckin'
emailing Americans being like,
"Stop making British memes.
"I don't say the word eight."
Shut the fuck up.
Be a little bitch and take your shit.
(everyone laughs)
We all get mocked, okay, it's 2021!
- But yeah, "Fear Factor."
- Yeah, anyway.
- "Spinach or carrots."
(everyone laughs)
- "Who the fuck eats celery?"
- "Celery without hummus."
(everyone laughs)
Americans, I don't actually believe this.
I'm joking.
This is a joke.
This is a bit.
- "Eat the celery or take
the hummus and go home."
No, but basically it's like,
you have to do something
gross or eat something gross.
And if you decide to do it,
then you move onto the next round.
If you don't decide to do
it, then you get kicked off.
And basically each step it just gets worse
and worse and worse.
I don't know.
I might be talking out my ass.
This is how I remember it.
- What the fuck is wrong with us?
Wanting to watch people do
fuckin' stupid shit like this.
- I don't know.
- It's entertaining.
- Actually I had another flashback
to another Derren Brown special.
He did another special
as well which is great
where the audience get to choose
whether something bad happened to the guy
or something good happened to the guy.
So they would follow a
guy in his daily life.
He obviously signed a bunch of things.
Literally the audience every
single time chose bad things.
(Joey laughs)
And like, one of them was, like,
his family gets Christmas presents early
or he gets fucking kidnapped.
And he literally got kidnapped
because the audience wanted
to see him get kidnapped.
We're fucked up!
We are fucked up!
- Do you know what the
most fucked up thing
about that special was?
- What?
- So the special basically ends
with the audience shows
a bad thing happening
like he got kidnapped or something.
And then I think as they
were trying to kidnap him,
he got into a car crash.
Now the car crash, the
car crash was staged.
The audience didn't know this.
The car crash was staged.
And so the audience see
him get hit by a car.
And then, they just like,
this unplanned thing.
Derren Brown just walks off.
And then you're just left seeing, like,
the audience kind of like-
- Really uncomfortable.
- Like, what's going on?
And like one of the
audience members going like,
"Excuse me, you're not being funny,
"but like this like-"
- "It's not our fault, is it?"
- I can't remember exactly what she says,
but she's like, "Excuse
me, this isn't funny.
"Like, can you tell us what's going on?
"Like, why would you make
him go through this?"
And it's, like, the lack of
self-awareness and self irony
that you literally came on a TV show-
- And kept voting.
- And kept voting for
bad things to happen.
And then something bad thing
happened that wasn't scripted,
but because it wasn't scripted,
suddenly it's a serious matter.
- Yeah, it was like really interesting.
'Cause it was basically just like you
as the audience does not
care about who is on screen.
You just want to see bad things happen.
You know, these are people.
It's really good.
- Because you know it's staged.
- 'Cause that's what you think.
You think it's all fake or
like, or you don't care.
- It was a message about, like, anonymity
within, like, crowds.
I don't know.
What's the word I'm looking for?
- Hive mind?
- Yeah, like the hive mindset
where if you have anonymity,
responsibility is kind
of like taken off you,
and you're willing to do, like,
you're willing to do things
that you might not do
if, you know, you were
the one responsible.
- I'm pretty sure I saw, like,
at least four, like,
"Black Mirror" episodes
that were like that.
- Yeah, but "Black Mirror" sucks now.
- Yeah, it sucks now.
- It sucks so much.
- It went downhill real fast.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Is there anything else you
guys want to bring up or?
- No, watch Derren Brown I guess.
This has been a really a strange episode.
We talked about so many things.
We sped run through stuff today.
But like watch Derren Brown.
That's all you gotta take away.
- I need to.
You guys sold me on it.
- Out of every British, like, you know,
I like to show Sydney
some British TV shows
because I feel like British TV shows,
people only know like fucking "Doctor Who"
and maybe "Top Gear," you know?
And I'm just like, you know,
British TV shows, they
have some good TV shows.
And I think Derren Brown is one
of the best examples you can get from
just quality TV shows
coming out from England.
- I mean, you guys have convinced me,
so that's what I'm gonna do.
- How can you not hear
any of that and be like,
"Yeah, I'm not really interested."
Like, you know what I mean?
It's so interesting.
- 'Cause the thing about British
TV shows is that they like,
he would make one special a year at most.
So, they'd obviously been
like dwelling on this idea
for like a long time.
So, like some ideas
are better than others,
but there's no idea that you hear about
and you think, "That's
not interesting at all."
- His one special he teaches old people
to, like, rob an art gallery.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That was one as well.
Yeah, that's good.
You should watch that.
It wasn't his best but it was good.
- That was a good one.
- I can do that or go
watch another episode
of "Don't Tell the Bride."
(everyone laughs)
- That's what it's called!
We figured it out!
- We didn't know what it's called!
Show's over now!
- And it's all come full circle.
- I figured it out.
"Don't Tell the Bride"
that's what it's called.
- I was thinking like "3,000
Pound Marriage" or something.
In UK it was 3,000, it was 3,000, right?
- I think it was 10,000.
- The episode's over now.
The "Trash Taste" episode's over now.
- Yeah, hey, look at all
these patrons though.
They're pretty cool.
- Before we end the episode,
I'm gonna find out how
much money it was now.
- Okay.
- All right, you do that.
But thank you to all our patrons.
And Joey, do the shout out.
- Okay, in the meantime, if
you want to support the show
then make sure to go over
to Patreon.com/TrashTaste.
Also follow us on Twitter,
send us your memes on the subreddit,
and if you hate our faces, go
and listen to us on Spotify.
Have you found out what it was yet?
I blitzed through that shit.
- It says, oh yeah,
they were given 12,000 pounds.
- Ooh.
- So, a bit more than I thought.
That sounds about right.
- Big boy money.
- That's actually a pretty decent-
- I knew it was a division of three.
- That's a decent amount of money.
- That's a decent budget that is.
- That's not bad.
- You can get away with
quite a bit for that.
- And this was like the TV episode then.
We didn't even intend for it to be.
- It just kind of like-
- That's every "Trash Taste" episode.
- We got to talk about trash TV.
I'm happy.
I mean-
- Our trash taste in TV.
- Oh, that's the title!
- Didn't get to talk about
my hatred of "Love Island,"
but you know, whatever.
- It's shit, Garnt.
What is there to say?
It's garbage.
- Yeah, I know.
Why is everyone watching it then, Connor?
- Save it for the next episode.
- All right, see you guys.
Have a good one.
Bye!
- Bye!
(chill music plays)